So, ja dafür muss ich den, dafür brauche ich das, was ich heute im Stream mache, nämlich dass wir Remote Unlocken können.
Was mit dem Stream passiert ist, ich habe irgendwelche Sachen geleakt, die ich nicht sehen wollte im Stream und deswegen habe ich den Stream gelöscht.
Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, was gewesen ist. Keine Ahnung.
Aber da gab es eh nichts Großartiges zu sehen, außer dass es tatsächlich ganz gut funktioniert auf der Kiste.
Ich bin mir aber trotzdem nicht sicher, was das Setup angeht. Ich habe jetzt Offstream schon ein bisschen umgebastelt noch und ganz ehrlich, ich bin da nicht so wirklich happy mit, wie es ist.
Also ob das mein 4M Setup ersetzen wird, ich bin da, ich bin da, ne, ne, ne, ne, gibt es nirgendwo mehr im Stream, das ist weg.
Aber ich glaube, wir richten das eh nochmal vom Scratch neu ein, wenn ich es halbwegs schön konfiguriert habe.
Dann kannst du dir das hier angucken und dann leake ich auch nix, hoffe ich.
Ja, da ist wahrscheinlich eh kaum was passiert, ja.
Alles Leute, da ist ja alles schon am Start sein. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, habe ich genug zu trinken hier?
Ja, ich habe 700 Milliliter Wasser hier. Ich habe so eine komische Anzeige auf der Trinkflasche und die steht jetzt bei knapp unter 700, das reicht jetzt erstmal.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Ich habe das unter 8.
Ich habe das unter 8 Linux noch nie gemacht, wie Essen, gegessen habe ich schon.
Ich habe das unter 8 Linux noch nie gemacht, aber als ich mir das angeguckt habe, habe ich festgestellt, also es gibt ja natürlich Arch Linux Wiki Eintrag und sowas.
Habe ich festgestellt, es ist anscheinend doch ein bisschen anders, als das auf Debian zu machen, weil auf Debian ist es ziemlich easy, Remote Festplatte, die verschlüsselt ist, zu unlocken.
Nämlich, da installierst du quasi Inetrum FS Drop Peels.
Und trägst zwei Sachen ein und es funktioniert.
So einfach ist es unter Arch, by the way, nicht.
Ich starte mal kurz meine VM, zeige ich euch das.
Ja, das ist auch so unser letzter Test.
Wir brauchen glaube ich noch, wir brauchen glaube ich noch eine neue VM.
Ich werde das auf jeden Fall auf einer VM machen, das ist einfach, da kann ich noch Snapshots machen, falls ich das Ding irgendwie kaputt mache oder so.
Nudeln mit Lachs gab es heute tatsächlich wieder, ja, korrekt.
Mein Chat kennt meinen Essensplan besser als ich.
Essensplan Hackermans.
Keck Alu.
Ja.
Ja klar, du musst es ja quasi schon, bevor du so richtig gebootet hast, laufen haben, dass du über SSH deine Festplatte entsperren kannst.
Also vielleicht soll ich das auch im Titel...
Naja, wir lassen den Titel so wie es ist.
Also, Sinn der Übung ist, wir haben eine vollverschlüsselte Festplatte.
Wir haben eine vollverschlüsselte Festplatte.
Mit Lux.
Und da musst du ja ein Passwort beim Booten eingeben.
Und dieses Passwort beim Booten musst du immer mit einer angeschlossenen Tastatur am jeweiligen Rechner eingeben, weil wie willst du das sonst machen?
Es sei denn, du schaffst, man schafft es irgendwie SSH zum Laufen zu kriegen schon davor.
Doch, doch, das geht.
Also, dass es geht, kann ich dir sicher sagen, weil ich das schon öfters auf Debian gemacht habe.
Und auf Ubuntu Server und bestimmt auch schon mal auf irgendeinem Red Hat System.
Aber ich habe das noch nie auf Archillungs gemacht.
Und ich habe, es gibt, machen wir den Kabel hier mal, gerade mal alles zu.
Machen wir mal Updates, Package Updates.
Ja, Arch, Linux, Unlock, SSH, Lux.
So, das gibt natürlich, selbstverständlich, ein Arch-Wiki-Eintrag da drüber.
Der ist aber Arch-Wiki-Eintrags-technisch vielleicht nicht unbedingt so das Zugänglichste, ja.
Und es scheint grundsätzlich das gleiche zu sein wie unter Debian, aber doch ein bisschen anders.
Es gibt nämlich zum Beispiel kein fertiges Paket, wo du das einfach installieren kannst und dann macht es das für dich.
Ja, und das probieren wir heute mal aus.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Wir probieren das übrigens nicht mit, wo stand es hier, mit Tiny-SSH, sondern wir machen das mit Drop-Beer.
Oder Beer, Drop-Beer ist es eher.
Nicht Bier, ist ja nicht hier, ja.
Monka besaufen.
Weil, den kenne ich, Tiny-SSH kenne ich nicht.
Ist denn Tiny-SSH überhaupt?
Gibt es das überhaupt noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise supported, gibt es das noch?
Nee, äh, GitHub Tiny-SSH, ich habe davon noch nie was gehört.
Äh, so semi, so semi-supported würde ich sagen.
Easy, simple, smaller Server mit knapp unter 100.000 Line-of-Codes.
Easy, obvious, self-documenting Software.
So, machen wir erstmal Updates.
Updates können nicht schaden.
Und wir können schon mal eine neue VM anlegen.
Die da heißen wird, Arch-Test, by the way.
Habe ich genug Platz auf meiner Main-Disk?
Ja, oh, da wird es langsam ein bisschen eng.
Der Rest ist eigentlich kaum ausgelastet, okay, nice.
Okay, next.
Number of Processors.
Fünf.
Nee, Cores.
Wir machen was ganz Scheppes.
Fünf Cores, nee, nee, nee, nicht 56.
Fünf Cores und 8GB, das sollte reichen zum Testen.
Bridge-Networking auf jeden Fall, mit NAT wird es nicht ordentlich funktionieren.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das, weder viel Speicherplatz noch viel CPU wird das SSH-Zeug brauchen.
So, create new disk, single, ja, keine Ahnung, 50G.
Komm, wir machen auch was Scheppes, 57G.
Heute machen wir Scheppe-Anzahl an allem.
Arch, by the way.
So.
Zack.
Printer kommt weg, Soundkarte kommt weg.
Ich habe übrigens letztes Mal probiert, wieder Hyperland laufen zu bekommen in der 4M.
Es funktioniert besser als mein letzter Test, aber wenn man Firefox startet, crasht die ganze 4M.
Nach ein paar Sekunden.
Das ist alles nicht so wirklich für 4M-Usage ausgelegt.
Deswegen, Accelerate 3D-Graphics können wir auch auslassen.
Ich kann es euch zeigen, wenn ihr wollt.
Wenn wir noch Zeit haben, installiere ich euch mal eine Runde Hyperland in der 4M.
Machen wir Accelerate 3D-Graphics.
Es funktioniert halt einfach gar nicht richtig.
Broken AF.
So, passt es so.
Ja, close.
Okay.
Finish.
Let's go.
So.
Äh, nein, nein, nein.
Erstmal kurz gucken, ob meine Package-Updates ordentlich installiert wurden.
Der Doktor wurde gespeichert.
Ich habe Zeug geleakt aus Versehen.
Den Stream habe ich gelöscht, aber für alle, die den Stream verpasst haben, ist nicht schlimm.
Ich habe das jetzt auf Stream schon ein bisschen weiter eingerichtet.
Und wenn ich das irgendwann mal in einem Zustand...
Zustand habe, wo ich sage, ey, das ist so, dass man es theoretisch verwenden könnte,
dann werden wir das vom Scratch nochmal neu einrichten,
weil ich habe mir noch eine zweite M.2 SSD gekauft für die Kiste.
Dann habe ich zwei M.2 SSD drin, von der ich quasi dual booten kann.
Und was gibt es Besseres zum Dual-Booten als zweimal Arch?
Oder? Was sagt ihr?
Arch Linux Dual Boot mit Arch Linux.
Das ist, glaube ich, das einzig Wahre, was man machen kann.
Eventuell, eventuell könnte man Manjaro und Arch Dual booten noch.
Aber nachdem ja die Manjaro-Hater mittlerweile sagen, Manjaro wäre kein Arch Linux,
ist das eigentlich auch raus, ja?
By the way, Arch geht nur mit Original-Arch.
Nicht mit Manjaro-Fake-Arch oder so Dinger.
Mac OS.
Ohne Mist, Mac OS würde ich sehr gerne ausprobieren auf dieser Kiste.
Okay.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob man das komplett legal machen kann
und dementsprechend, ob man das streamen kann.
Was ist das für ein Mini-PC?
Ich habe eine China-Chinesen-Kiste, selbstverständlich China-Chinesen-Kiste.
Das ist ein Beelink, sehr...
Eine gute Frage.
Sieben oder fünf?
Ich muss mal kurz drauf gucken.
Ich glaube, sieben.
Ja.
Aber zählt Arch mit Installer?
Überhaupt, ja.
Hoffe mal.
So eine Kiste ist das hier.
Die in echt bei weitem nicht so eklig aussieht wie auf diesem Bild.
Eigentlich recht nice, denn man bekommt...
Ja, also was ich richtig blöd finde, ich habe es euch ja im letzten Stream gezeigt,
wer dabei war mit der Kamera, haben wir das Ding ja unboxed.
Also was richtig räudig ist, ist dieser komische Power-Plug,
den man unten mit Magnet dran macht.
Warum hat er nicht einen ganz normalen so...
Ja.
Holstecker hat, wie es da normal...
Weiß bei, keine Ahnung, das ist krank.
Also der Power-Plug ist krank.
Ansonsten ist das Ding eigentlich relativ gut.
Du hast da den Display-Port.
Vorne, zweimal hinten, USB-C.
Vorne, hinten ist so ein Audio-Headset-Kombi-Ding.
Normale USB, 2,5 Gigahertz-Laden.
Und vorne noch zwei weitere USBs dran.
Also, oder?
Ich glaube...
Ne, ein.
Und nur USB-C.
Und sogar ein BIOS-Reset.
Also ich finde das Ding nicht schlecht.
Muss mal gucken, dass man es halbwegs günstig kriegt.
Das ist schon ein bisschen der teureren Variante.
Ja.
Also für die Kiste probieren wir das mit dem Remote-Unlocken aus.
Weil es macht ja keinen Sinn, dass ich da eine Tastatur dran haben muss.
Muss ich bei meiner VM ja auch nicht.
Also es gibt eigentlich genau einen, der sich bei solchen Geräten etabliert hat.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, welche Größe das ist.
2,5 Gigahertz.
Äh.
Gigabit.
Das Ding hat das Ding gar nicht mehr.
Das hat nur noch zwei Slots für M.2-SSDs.
Ja.
Also bei diesen Hole-Steckern, da hat sich doch eigentlich genau ein Format so für 12 Volt oder was ist denn das?
24 Volt DC oder so etabliert.
USB-C-Power fände ich auch vollkommen fein.
Aber dieser proprietäre Magnetstecker, der ist echt nicht so geil.
So, Arch-By-The-Way ist, äh, Updated, Outdated, Overhead.
12,5 Volt haben viele.
Ja, dann sollen sie einen 24-Volt-DC-Stecker, ah ja, excellent.
Chat, ich glaube, genau das haben wir jetzt gebraucht.
Das müssen wir hier hinschreiben.
Weiß nicht, weiß nicht, warum ich da, warum, warum, Chat, warum habe ich hier Face-Rolled über die Tastatur einmal?
Oh!
Die Chatbrains-Toolbox sieht jetzt modern aus.
Seit wann ist denn das so?
Die sieht ja richtig Web 7.0 aus.
Seit wann haben die das geupdatet?
Seit heute? Wirklich?
Sagst du das jetzt einfach nur so oder ist das echt so?
Also es kann doch nicht so lang sein, weil es hat gerade geupdatet und ich hatte den, die VM, was weiß ich, drei Tage oder so nicht an.
Also lange kann es nicht sein.
Ah, Exposed.
Exposed.
Mit AI, die sagt, guck mal Leute, das ist, seht ihr das, seht ihr das?
Fake Transparency im Hintergrund.
Wobei, ja, das ist Fake Transparency im Hintergrund, Leute.
Eindeutig.
Guck mal, das ist Fake Transparency im Hintergrund.
Da bewegt sich im Hintergrund was, aber das ist nicht das Bild, was sich da bewegt, oder?
Das ist Fake, oder ist das?
Weil.
Ich kann die Bewegung nicht irgendwie mit dem Hintergrundbild in Einklang bringen.
Es scheint mir Fake zu sein.
Vielleicht, vielleicht Fake ist mein Hirn aber auch Fake.
Zu wenig Fake Detector.
So, jetzt haben wir aber Updates gemacht, alles gut.
So, haben wir denn eigentlich ein Netboot-Image hier?
Das ist immer mit Abstand am Angen, haben wir Netboot, da, beste.
Okay, also Chat, der Plan ist folgendes.
Also wofür wir es machen ist, ich habe mir so eine Mini-PC-Kiste gemacht.
Ich habe sie gekauft, aber auf der machen wir das heute nicht.
Ich habe da einen Arch-Linux drauf gehauen, voller encrypted Disk und will die jetzt remote entsperren.
Nachdem ich die Kiste jetzt aber nicht kaputt machen will, mit irgendwelchen Basteleien am Bootloader und allem, installiere ich nochmal schnell, das dauert 10 Minuten oder so, Arch-Linux in der VM, mit voller encrypted Festplatte, virtueller Festplatte und dann versuchen wir mal einzurichten, dass man das übers Netzwerk entsperren kann.
Und ihr seht dann auch, wie es aussieht.
Das Netzwerk entsperrt wird.
Ne, manchmal gucken wir uns mal, machen wir eine schnelle, machen wir mal, was, was so, was, IDE1, was will der Typ von mir?
Das ist die, das ist die Disk, dann starten wir mal, die Arch-Linux-Installation.
Äh, jetzt muss man schnell sein.
Bam, bam, bam, nein, ich war zu langsam.
Ich weiß, dass das anders geht, aber ich versuche das immer, das ist so wie so ein, wie so ein Minigame.
Ah, ich bin heute zu langsam.
Was ist denn?
Warum bin ich denn heute so lahm?
Normalerweise ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Ach so, ah, die ist, die Festplatte ist gar nicht dran.
Keck, wait.
Deswegen geht das nicht.
Lull.
Muss doch mal gesagt werden.
Ja, aber ich habe das Minigame trotzdem gefailt.
Normalerweise geht da ein Boot-Menü auf und man kann auswählen, möchten Sie booten von Disk, von Festplatte und so.
Ich kann übrigens jedem nur netbootxyz empfehlen.
Wer nicht gerade immer irgendwie einen Ventoy-Stick dabei hat mit den aktuellsten ISOs.
Und selbst da würde ich das netbootxyz drauf machen.
Netboot ist ein Mini-ISO, das ist nur, keine Ahnung, 15 MB oder sowas groß.
Ja, zwei, zwei MB, zwei MB großes ISO, was so einen Einstiegs-, was im Prinzip einfach nur ein Menü bootet, wo du dann auswählen kannst, was du weiter booten willst.
Sehr praktisch.
Ich benutze eigentlich nichts anderes mehr zum Installieren.
So, Linux Network Install, das wollen wir haben.
Acht, by the way.
Oh, natürlich dauert das jetzt beim Initialen.
Äh, okay, das hatte ich noch nicht.
Ist das gerade irgendwie down oder so?
Oder ist, ist vielleicht mein ISO, oh, jetzt hängt das Ding, äh, ist vielleicht mein ISO zu alt?
Ey, jetzt hat meine Veröffentlichung, ist mein ISO zu alt vielleicht?
Ich glaube, ne.
Netbootxyz, ich lade mir mal das neueste ISO runter.
Normalerweise halten diese ISOs ewig, weil das, ne, es hat exakt, exakt die, na!
Zwei, zwei Kilo bei dem Unterschied.
Äh, by the way, kann meine VM mal ausgehen, so, einfach?
Ne.
Kann's, kann's nicht.
VM ist auch schon ganz schön eine Ppega-Software teilweise, oder?
Jetzt habe ich auf runterfahren geklickt und in dem Zustand schnappt die,
da hat die VM sich noch keine, wie heißen diese Power-Button-Press-Events?
Ah, jetzt ist es aus, okay, nice.
Ah, wisst ihr, was auch sein kann?
Dass ich die UEFI-Variante runtergeladen habe und nicht UEFI gebootet habe.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, aber um das jetzt auszuschließen, booten wir, booten wir einfach vom allerneuesten ISO, gutes.
Oder ISO, wie das manche Leute auch sagen.
Aber ich, ich bin eher für ISO.
Wie ist das bei euch so, Leute?
ISO oder ISO?
Linux Network Installed.
Achtsch, Linux, achtsch.
Wisst ihr, zack, funktioniert.
Ja, der lädt jetzt auch was anderes runter, oder?
ISO, ja, ich, ich bin auch für ISO.
ISO, Allah.
Ja, der, der...
ISO war wieder ein anderer.
Als ich noch Bock hatte, Assassin's Creed zu spielen, war das...
Die neuesten Teile gingen so an mir vorbei.
Den einzigen Assassin's Creed-Teil, den ich nochmal nachholen möchte...
Also, ich hab Ezio gelesen.
Den einzigen letzten, der letzten Jahre Assassin's Creed-Teil, den ich nachholen will, ist das in Ägypten.
Aber ansonsten gehen die mir alle sonst wo vorbei.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich auch ausgelutscht.
Ausgelutscht.
So.
Initiale booten dauert natürlich ein bisschen länger.
Weil man jetzt nicht im Vorfeld den ISO runtergeladen hat.
Sondern quasi jetzt Netboot gebootet hat.
Und Netboot lädt jetzt das ISO runter und startet das ISO.
Deswegen dauert das immer ein bisschen.
Aber trotzdem ist das sehr angenehm.
Ich starte, ich installiere quasi nur noch von Netboot.
Und noch besser, man kann Netboot auch über PXE verteilen.
Da muss man gar nicht von der ISO booten.
Dafür ist es sogar ursprünglich mal gedacht gewesen.
Und dann kann man einfach irgendeinen x-beliebigen Rechner booten im Netzwerk.
Über PXE.
Und hat Netboot XYZ und kann jedes x-beliebige Linux starten.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Das finde ich gar nicht mal schlecht.
Ich muss das ehrlich sagen.
Ich fand das Kampfsystem in den alten Assassin's Creed ehrlich gesagt nie sonderlich toll.
Du musst es einfach nur möglichst heimengenau die Attacke drücken, dass du alles one-shottet.
Also das war nicht so geil.
Download von Körnel.org ist nicht so schnell.
Michael, 50 Milliarden.
Moin, danke schön für deinen, ich wollte gerade sagen Sub, aber du bist einfach nur so da.
Es war auch nice, dass du da bist.
Die Weeps sind hier.
Moin.
Oder um dich mal auf richtige, auf Weep-Augenhöhe zu begrüßen.
Ohayo.
Michael Chan.
So, ist dein Kram jetzt runtergeladen?
Jetzt aber.
Ich habe übrigens gelernt, dass Hyperland ein Anime-Girl-Maskottchen hat.
Was anscheinend die erste Linux-Desktop-Umgebung ist.
Das haben sie schon abgeschwächt, weil sich die Leute beschwert haben,
dass random Anime-Girls auf ihrem Desktop-Hintergrund auftauchen.
Jetzt gibt es nur noch eine von drei Hintergründen, wo Hyper-Chan drauf ist.
Nee.
Nee, diesen Stream nicht mehr.
Nächsten Stream wieder.
So, wie war das?
Setup Arch?
Nee.
Arch.
Arch-Install war es.
Hyper-Chan.
Ja, hier.
Leute.
Ja.
Hyperland.
Hyper-Chan.
Oh, nein, nein.
Nicht Hyper.
Hyper-Chan.
Dann guck.
Da haben sich die Leute beschwert, dass es teilweise random Anime-Girls gibt auf dem Desktop-Hintergrund.
Randomized.
Und das wollten die nicht haben.
Okay.
Aber generell konnte der sich nicht durchsetzen gegen die geballte Weep-Power.
Hyper-Chan darf nicht komplett disabled werden.
Wer sich fragt, was wollen die eigentlich von mir?
Die haben irgendwo die Wallpaper.
Wallpapers?
Ich finde das nicht.
Keine Ahnung, wo die Wallpapers sind.
Zumindest haben sie es nicht.
Zumindest haben sie es ab, haben sie es etwas abgeschwächt.
Es gibt jetzt nur noch, es gibt drei Hintergründe und nur eine, ein Hintergrund mit Hyper-Chan.
So, also, dann machen wir das jetzt mal hier im Schnelldurchlauf.
Ich mache mal für euch ein bisschen größer, dass der Chat, dass der Chat was sehen kann.
So.
Also, Englisch, Mirrors, Mirror Region, German.
Hat er das jetzt gecheckt eigentlich?
Ja, Alter.
So.
Ähm.
Wait a minute.
Wo, wo, wo?
Ihr Lokal ist, das will ich haben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wo können wir denn jetzt die Tastatur auswählen?
Äh, Tastatur-Layout ist DE.
Der Rest darf durchaus auf Englisch stehen bleiben.
System Debut machen wir nicht, weil auf meiner echten Hardware-Kiste ist es auch ein Crap,
der drauf ist.
Disk-Configuration müssen wir machen.
Best-Effort-Partitioning ist okay.
Warum ist das eigentlich immer noch ein Ding?
Dass alle Festplattengrößen in unterschiedlichen Einheiten rechnen.
Können wir uns jetzt mal irgendwie drauf verständigen, ob wir in Gigabyte oder in Gebibyte
oder in Hyper-Chan-Byte oder in was auch immer rechnen?
No, wir wollen alles auf die gleiche.
So.
Disk-Encryption.
Passwort super kompliziert, kommt ihr nie drauf.
Wie?
Fake News.
Das Passwort ist nicht weak.
Guck mal, das unterstützt übrigens auch direkt im Installer mittlerweile so Sachen
wie einen Yubi-Key oder sowas.
Eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Ich habe keinen hier.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht.
Wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren.
So.
Back, Swap, True, Ausnahme, Arch, Tests, by the way.
Root-Passwort brauchen wir nicht.
User-Account, Add User, Max.
Auch super highly komplexes Passwort.
Er soll Sudo-Rechte haben.
Confirm.
Profil.
Mir wurscht.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Audio.
Audio-Unterliebungs...
Nix.
Additional Packages.
Brauchen wir da irgendwas?
Git.
Aber eigentlich egal.
Äh.
Haartop.
Eigentlich wurscht.
SSH.
Open-SSH brauchen wir.
Ja.
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Ist das Open-SSH?
Ja.
OpenSSH oder ist es OpenSSH Server mit Minus dabei? Ich glaube es ist unter Arch einfach nur OpenSSH.
Wenn man hier was eingibt, was es nicht gibt. Ah, dann sagt er, dass es das nicht gibt. Okay, OpenSSH. Also gibt es das. Nice.
Network Configuration, Network Manager, Time Zone. Ja, Berlin, Sync, Optional Repositories, ist jetzt egal, brauchen wir nicht.
Äh, Install. Enter. Let's go. So, und jetzt werdet ihr gleich das Problem sehen, was ich fixen will beim ersten Reboot.
Wir können übrigens gleich noch was machen. Ich kann mal meinen, wenn wir dann am Bootmanager rumbasteln, kann ich den mal absichtlich kaputt machen.
Und dann kann ich euch zeigen, wie man das Ganze mit einer Linux Live CD wieder fixen kann. Selbst wenn man sein System unbootable gemacht hat.
Was?
Hey, Linux hat ein VTuber-Grill als Kernel-Developer. Ja, sie sind überall.
Welche Passwortmanager?
Keepers. Seit Jahren Keepers. 1 vs. 1, lol. Oh, und irgendwelche semi-legalen Seiten, die hier empfohlen werden.
Warum empfiehlt Windows, wenn man nach 1 sucht eigentlich? So komische Seiten.
Und das liegt nicht irgendwie an meiner History.
Wie gesagt, ich habe hauptsächlich Keepers. Ich habe mir in letzter Zeit schon mehr Sachen angeguckt.
Ja, auch mal, also was ja, was ja quasi gerade bei den ganzen Reddit-Self-Hostern, das probieren wir auch damit aus.
Ah, wer braucht Security-Patches?
Ja, was ja gerade bei den ganzen Self-Hostern sehr beliebt ist, ist Bitwarden.
Bitwarden. Zumindest war das die ganze Zeit. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch die angesagte Sache ist.
Das ändert sich ja öfters mal.
Und das habe ich auch ausprobiert. Das war schon okay. Das kann man verwenden.
Aber es hat mich jetzt nicht so überzeugt, dass ich gesagt habe, boah, da ist es ja alle so viel besser und meilenweit vorne.
Und ja, stimmt, Bitwarden ist ja gar nicht mehr.
Waldwarden ist es jetzt, weil die sich ja beschwert haben, dass die sich einfach gleich genannt haben.
Und ich bleibe einfach bei Keepers.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe den großen Vorteil davon nicht, dass jetzt...
Auszulagern. Ja, ich verstehe. Insofern, natürlich hat es einen gewissen Vorteil, wenn das Passwort-Zeug nicht...
Der Save nicht auf dem gleichen System liegt, wie wo du dir vielleicht irgendwie Malware eingefangen haben kannst.
Aber letztendlich musst du damit rechnen, dass irgendwie einer ein Root-Gate auf deinem Rechner und Remote-Access hat.
Dann ist das auch egal.
Kann man bei Keepers auch OTP machen? Ja, kannst du.
Gibt es Plugins für? Und ich glaube sogar, ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, weil ich mache OTP nicht darüber.
Das Keeper ist mittlerweile sogar ein OTP-Generator eingebaut.
Aber da wäre ich vorsichtig. Da muss man jetzt mal ein Disclaimer sagen.
Es heißt ja nicht umsonst Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Also wenn ich mein OTP im gleichen Passwort-Save speichere, wie mein Hauptpasswort,
dann kann man sich darüber streiten, ob das jetzt wirklich noch ein zweiter Faktor ist.
Also wenn ihr quasi die gleiche Software benutzt für euer Main-Passwort und dann für den zweiten Faktor,
ist ja eigentlich der zweite Faktor weg.
Also was ich eine ganze Weile verwendet habe auf dem Handy, aber was auf gar keinen Fall,
nicht, dass man das jetzt irgendwie als Empfehlung versteht,
Dr. Pronoops, danke schön für den Hypo-Sub,
was ich auf gar keinen Fall will, dass man das hier als Empfehlung versteht,
was ich die ganze Zeit verwendet habe, was ich aber nicht mehr verwende,
weil die es richtig verkackt haben, war auf iOS Revio-OTP oder so hieß das.
Ravio, Ravio-OTP.
Ja, das war eigentlich die ganze Zeit ganz nice bis vor ein paar Wochen.
Verwendet das auf gar keinen Fall mehr, ja.
Ich sag's, kannst du 580 mal sagen.
Du hast Hyper-Chan gefunden.
Nice.
Okay.
Dann will ich euch die Allgemeinbildungslücke nicht vorenthalten.
GitHub, Hyperland, Assets, Wallpaper 2.
Das ist neues Hyper-Chan, das ist neues Hyper-Chan.
Bitte meint nicht.
Wo ist altes Hyper-Chan?
Das Alte brauchen wir.
Muss man mal hier.
Ja.
Nein, das ist noch das All.
Das ist, das ist, das ist neues Hyper, ich brauch das alte Hyper-Chan.
Da kann ich eure, eure Desktop-Dings-Maskottchen-Wissenslücke doch nicht schließen.
Die gab's auch in der anderen Variante.
Ohne 3D gerendert.
Ja, also, jetzt mal diese Zwei-Faktor-Geschichte abzuhören.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit das hier verwendet auf iOS.
Und das hat ja auch ganz gute, ganz gute Bewertungen gekriegt.
War eine Open-Source-App auf YouTube, äh, nicht auf YouTube, auf GitHub.
Das Ding ist nur, die App wurde verkauft an irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, China-Chinesen oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Und die haben's dann geschafft, das war kompletter Clusterfuck, Leute.
Kompletter Clusterfuck.
Okay.
Die haben ein Software-Up
Und haben es doch tatsächlich geschafft.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man es schaffen kann.
Guck, und seitdem, seitdem ist übrigens Funkstille.
Seitdem hier ist Funkstille.
Seitdem posten die nix mehr.
Die haben die App, die haben die App geupdatet.
Also der ursprüngliche Entwickler hat die App verkauft.
Und die haben die App geupdatet und haben alle Passwörter, die da drin gespeichert,
waren und otp tokens gelöscht aus versehen oder nicht aus versehen die
wollten die leute nehmen in irgendein abosystem zwingen dadurch und eines
morgens mache ich meine otp app auf und soll mich neu anmelden und habe ich mir
schon gedacht moment da stimmt irgendwas irgendwas ist das leider waren sie
natürlich auch so schlau aus business enterprise sicht und haben die export
funktion deaktiviert das heißt es neue war nicht mal zugreifbar und du konntest
nicht mehr exportieren also arschkarte wenn man sich exportiert hat so und was
habe ich gemacht ich hätte natürlich meine otp ist
zurücksetzen können und so was deswegen ist immer wichtig dass man sich wenn man
zwei faktor oder ohne scheiß leute wenn ihr eine sache macht beim zwei faktoren
oder ohne scheiß leute wenn ihr eine sache macht beim zwei faktoren oder ohne scheiß leute wenn ihr eine sache macht beim zwei faktoren
authentifizierungen aktiviert ist das speichert euch die notfall passwörter
irgendwo zu euch zu nun auch so legt zu euch in schrank weil wenn ihr
beispielsweise kein zugriff auf euren google-account habt und eure ganzen zwei
faktor geräte sind weg ihr könnt euch mit diesen codes immer
noch einloggen bis zu zehn mal gibtst bis zu zehn codes kannst du gerne heb
dir euch auf weil man denkt sich so aber was soll dann passieren dass auf einem
handy drauf
Zum Beispiel, wenn der App-Hersteller seine App verkauft und das Update eure ganzen OTPs löscht und kaputt macht.
Dann habt ihr gelesen, da könnt ihr euch nicht mehr drauf einloggen.
Es wird oftmals unterschätzt, man denkt, das ist doch nur der zweite Faktor.
Ne, wenn der zweite Faktor weg ist, könnt ihr euch ohne die Reserve-Codes nicht mehr einloggen.
Und das betrifft alle Accounts.
Manche Hersteller oder manche Anbieter wie Amazon haben beispielsweise gar keine Recovery-Codes und sowas.
Zumindest was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ist folgendes.
Ich habe die App zum ersten Mal geöffnet.
An dem Tag habe ich schon gedacht, oh fuck, da ist irgendwas verkehrt.
Genau, hier haben sie ja auch gepostet, dass sie das verkauft haben.
Also, ich habe zwei Sachen gemacht.
Ich habe downgradet.
Habt ihr schon...
Also, ich habe nichts weiter in der App gemacht.
Ich habe die App einfach wieder geschlossen, nachdem ich das geguckt habe.
Im Internet gesucht, festgestellt, die App wurde verkauft und es gab ein Update und es ist kaputt.
Übrigens, der Kauf hat sich nicht gelohnt.
Seit der letzten Newsreel.
Post von denen, wo es sehr viel böses Blut gab und die auch die automatischen Antworten ausgeschaltet haben,
ist Funkstille auf dem Twitter-Kanal.
Die haben sich einfach von heute auf morgen ihre komplette Userbase vertrieben.
Also, der Kauf hat sich nicht gelohnt für die.
So, was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich habe die App geschlossen und dachte mir, okay, lass die App downgraden.
Auf dem Stand, bevor das Ganze war und wo noch alles ging.
Leute, habt ihr schon mal unter iOS eine App?
Habt ihr schon mal jemanden gemacht von euch?
Unter Android ist das relativ easy.
System, CTL, Enable, SSH, D.
Achso, ja gut, ich bin in einem...
Also, ich kann euch sagen, App-Downgrades unter iOS ist der größte, wirklich der allergrößte Abfuck.
Du musst...
Ich habe das nach einer Anleitung gemacht.
Weiß nicht, ob ich die noch finde auf die Schnelle.
Ich reboote die.
Ich reboote die Kiste hier mal schnell und dann gucken wir uns das an.
Ich habe das nach einer Anleitung gemacht hier.
Downgrade iOS-Apps.
Das war irgendeine Anleitung als Gist auf this Guide.
Ja, also, anhand dieses Guides habe ich das gemacht.
Welche OTP-App ich anstattdessen jetzt benutze.
Also, ich habe jetzt...
Off.
Ente-Auth.
Die ist nämlich...
Das ist quasi...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Fork von dem alten Ravio ist, aber die ist auch Open Source und auf GitHub.
Und ich habe ein Backup von dem File.
Und ich habe auch noch zusätzlich den Microsoft Authenticator am Start.
Für ein paar Sachen.
So.
Zumindest, ich habe das anhand dieser Anleitung gemacht.
Und Leute, ich scrolle jetzt nochmal kurz drüber.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht im Detail an.
Aber, wenn ihr euch das hier schon anguckt, ja.
Du brauchst eine Windows-Installation.
Damit geht es los.
Du brauchst eine Windows-Installation mit iTunes drauf.
Also, habe ich eine VM installiert mit iTunes drauf.
So.
Dann habe ich diesen ganzen Shit hier durchgemacht.
Dann musst du einen Proxy installieren.
Mit SSL-Zertifikaten, der deine Requests zu Apple interceptet.
Dann musst du ein paar Requests über iTunes machen.
Musst dir die Download-URL von der alten App raussuchen.
Und dann musst du den...
Den Request zum Downloaden der neuen App-Version intercepten.
Und die alte App-Version eintragen.
Und dann hast du Glück und bekommst auf deinem iOS-Gerät die alte App-Version drauf.
Guckt euch mal diese Anleitung an.
Downgrade von der App?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das nicht eine eingebaute Funktion ist.
Manchmal sind neue Versionen halt karrierenverbackt.
So.
Und dann musst du das mit einer extra Software installieren.
App-Manager.
Kannst du jetzt rüberziehen.
Das habe ich gemacht.
Und dann hatte ich die alte App-Version bei mir drauf.
Auf meinem iPhone.
Konnte meine OTPs wieder öffnen.
Habe gleich nochmal einen Export gemacht.
Und jetzt verwende ich iOS-Ante-Auth.
Von dem Microsoft Authenticator.
Ante-Auth habe ich eigentlich auch nur deswegen verwendet.
Weil die...
Einzel-Auth-Auth.
Weil die zu eins das Format von dem alten gefressen haben.
Und importieren konnten.
Also es ist aber echt kompletter Witz.
Wirklich komplett lächerlich.
Wie dumm umständlich es ist.
Eine App zu downgraden.
Unter iOS.
Bei sowas hat Apple echt komplett...
Den Arsch offen.
So. Also.
Kommen wir mal zurück zu Art-Schildungs-Entsperren über SSH.
Ich habe Art-Schildungs installiert, Leute.
Und was bekomme ich jetzt beim Reboot?
Ich bekomme eine Meldung.
Damit ich weiter booten kann.
Damit ich weiter booten kann, muss ich ein Passwort eingeben.
Ja, logisch.
Wenn die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt ist.
Es ist alles voll verschlüsselt, außer Slash-Boot.
Muss ich, bevor ich richtig boot, ein Passwort eingeben.
Und mein Ziel heute ist, dass ich das hier, was ich jetzt quasi mit angeschlossener Tastatur mache,
über SSH erledigen kann.
Sodass ich eben nicht an dem Rechner, wo ich das machen will, eine Tastatur brauche.
Und eventuell sogar noch ab und zu ein Monitor, wenn ich mich mal vertippe oder so.
Also.
Das ist heute die Herausforderung.
Was habe ich denn für eine IP gekriegt?
1, 4, 5.
Also.
SSH max add 1, 4, 5.
Yes.
Excellent.
Okay.
Da sind wir drauf.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich User-Repos brauche.
Aber wir machen das mal schnell.
Weil das ist in einer...
Ein Befehl erledigt.
Go.
Nicht Rust.
Wie heißt das andere Ding, was jetzt angesagt ist?
Die coolen Leute verwenden das ja gar nicht mehr.
Die coolen Leute verwenden, glaube ich, Paru mittlerweile für User-Repos.
Weil Paru ist...
Ihr werdet das kaum erraten, Leute.
Was meint ihr, was der Unterschied zwischen Paru und Yay ist?
Als Package-Manager.
Ich kann euch schon spoilern.
Es ist eigentlich kein Unterschied, den ich als User interessieren sollte.
Aber der Unterschied ist, Paru ist...
Written in Rust.
Und selbstverständlich verwenden die richtig coolen Leute ein Package-Manager written in Rust.
Obviously.
Und Yay ist nur written in Go.
Und Go ist natürlich eindeutig viel weniger cool als Rust.
Da sind die Krustentiere wieder am Start.
Rust.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Für mich ist es...
Wisst ihr, was der Grund ist, warum ich bisher nicht gewechselt bin?
Weil sich Yay easy eingeht.
Das ist im Prinzip einfach nur auf A und...
Also natürlich könnte ich Paru einfach aliassen oder so.
Aber habe ich nicht.
So.
Wie dem auch sei.
Jetzt lasst uns doch mal gucken, wie wir das mit dem Remote-Entsperren hinkriegen.
Also es gibt einen Eintrag im Arch-Wiki.
Nämlich das hier.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Aber wir probieren das mal aus.
Als erstes, bevor wir anfangen, mache ich mal einen Snapshot.
Dass ich die Installation nicht nochmal neu machen muss.
Sollte ich es irgendwie verkacken.
Okay, also.
Booting from a removable device.
Bla bla bla.
Das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Hier, das ist wurscht.
Das braucht doch keiner.
Soll das alles sein hier?
Wen juckt denn das?
Das muss uns alles nicht interessieren.
Remote Unlocking of Root Partition.
Das muss uns interessieren hier.
Genau.
Busy Box Based Init RAM FS.
Das brauchen wir.
Okay.
Also.
Wir brauchen anscheinend NetConf.
DropBear.
Wir benutzen DropBear, nicht TinySSH.
Irgendjemand sagt, es wurde seit 5 Jahren nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Ah ja.
Fehlerfreie Software braucht keine Updates.
Außerdem ist das ja nur das Skript.
Es ist ja nur das Skript letztendlich.
Und nicht DropBear selber.
Und ich meine, wir reden hier irgendwie über 140 Zeilen Bash-Skript.
Ich glaube, das kann ich verstehen, dass das seit 5 Jahren nicht mehr geupdatet wurde.
Das wird wahrscheinlich echt einfach funktionieren.
Also, dann installieren wir das Ganze doch mal.
DropBear3.
Das da brauchen wir.
Massive geheimes Passwort.
Jawohl.
Baut auch schon neu.
Und NetConf brauchen wir.
Okay.
Was?
NFS-Utils?
Warum NFS?
Achso, dass ich theoretisch meine Root-Disk über Netzwerk-Laufwerk mounten könnte.
Wollen wir aber nicht.
Okay.
Und ich muss installen.
mkinit
Kann man das vielleicht auch mal in irgendeiner Aussprechbar machen?
mkinit cpio-utils
Okay, let's go.
Auch installieren.
So, was kommt hier als nächstes?
Instructions below can be used in any combination of the packages above when there is a document.
If you don't have a SSH key pair yet, generate one.
Doch, doch, ich habe genug SSH key pairs.
Insert your SSH public key.
Ah, okay.
Root key.
Insert your SSH public key.
You usually put onto hosts that you can SSH into without password.
Okay, also.
Dann machen wir doch mal.
Probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Ähm, das heißt SSH copy ID.
Welche, was ist denn meine Standard-ID?
ID R S A Z G.
Ja, ich, das, den will ich verwenden, ja.
Der ist gut, ja.
Bester, besser Key.
Mal gucken, ob der jetzt so einfach funktioniert auch.
Ne.
Der benutzt den Key gar nicht.
Aber wenn ich den richtigen Key auswähle, dann.
ID R S A Z G.
Okay, funktioniert. Passwortless.
Okay, den verwenden wir jetzt.
ID R S A Z G.
Kein ID 25519.
Hab ich auch am Start bestimmt.
Wir können auch den hier benutzen.
Wir machen einfach, wir kopieren einfach beide.
Wir kopieren einfach beide.
Okay.
So, jetzt haben wir Punkt SSH
Authorized Keys.
Less ist nicht drauf.
Okay, so langsam kann man es aber mit
mit Minimalismus
ein bisschen auch übertreiben.
So, ein Less brauchen wir.
Und ich würde sagen, einen WIM brauchen wir auch.
Irgendwie, dass man mal eine gescheite
Datei editieren kann.
Punkt SSH Authorized Keys.
Also, wir haben hier Max at Stream
und Wubblors
at gmx.de. By the way, kein
E-Mail-Adressen-Leak. Das ist die Adresse, die wir haben.
Die auch bei mir als Ansprechdingsbums
für die ganzen Streaming-Sachen
eingetragen ist.
No leak.
So.
Dann nehmen wir einfach mal die zwei Keys.
Kann ich mich jetzt da drauf verbinden auf
die Kiste ohne Passwort?
Ne.
Oh, aber was?
Ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen zu sehr rumgewurschtelt.
Wir bleiben mal bei dem
ZGKey.
Dann mache ich es nicht kaputt.
Wisst ihr was? Wir generaten.
Wir generaten uns dafür für diesen Test
einfach einen neuen Key.
Github generate
SSH-Key.
Ich brauche keine Github-Anleitung, um einen SSH-Key
zu generaten. Aber
ich weiß, dass Github
immer ein Example hat dafür.
So.
Username ist omegalul.
Generaten wir mal einen neuen Key.
Wie nennen
wir den?
Ich will den eigentlich ungern überschreiben.
Was passiert eigentlich?
Ah, override already existent.
No.
Moin Patrick.
Komm, wir bleiben.
Leute, ist doch egal.
Wir bleiben einfach bei dem Key hier.
Bei dem hier oben.
Gutes.
So, haben wir hier drauf.
So, wie geht es weiter?
Also wir können uns zumindest jetzt per SSH einloggen.
Ohne, dass
wir einen Key brauchen. Also das funktioniert.
Das ist nur das, was wir hier geschrieben haben.
Und jetzt sollen wir das
moven nach
etc.dropbar
rootkey.
Ok.
Also im Prinzip soll ich mein
authorize-key-file moven nach
etc.dropbar.
Da ist nichts drin.
Ups.
rootkey
permission denied. Ja,
jetzt bin ich hier rum.
Ist bei Linux Mint
eigentlich soweit? Ja, Linux Mint kannst du auch auf
der Box verwenden. Ich habe meinem Vater auch
Linux Mint auf so einem Mini-PC
installiert und er kommt damit anscheinend ganz gut klar.
Also schließe ich
einfach daraus, weil der mich
die letzten
drei Wochen oder so nicht mehr angerufen
hat, dass irgendwie was mit seinem Computer ist.
Also quasi seit er Linux
Mint hat, braucht er kaum noch Support.
Das, was ich sehr begrüße.
Weil
ihr wisst, wie gerne ich PC End-User
Support mache. Und ganz
ehrlich, wenn mein Vater damit klarkommt,
der schon sehr, also
extrem planlos ist, was Computer angeht,
dann kommst du auf jeden
Fall damit klar.
Achso, aber ist der SSH mit Lux
über Dropbar? Ne. Also was du
bei, ne ne, mir fällt auch keine
Distribution ein, wo das standardmäßig schon
der Fall ist und am Installer auswählbar wäre.
Also was du bei Mint machen kannst, ist
du kannst im Installer
Festplatten-Vollverschlüsselung machen.
Aber um Remote Unlocking über
SSH musst du dich selbst kümmern.
Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst dein
Home verschlüsseln lassen im Installer
schon. Und dann bootest du
quasi bis zum Login-Screen und
dann gibst du dein Passwort ein und
damit wird es verschlüsselt. Also
das ist so ne, so
ein Kompromiss da draus.
Aber wie gesagt, das musst du, das musst du
ziemlich sicher unter Mint auch selbst machen.
Okay.
Wie geht's jetzt weiter?
Simply copying the content of remote
Yeah, haben wir ja, haben wir ja.
Und wir sollen unser Kernel-Zeug
Bootkrempel neu generaten.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Silverlight!
Ist aber auch schon ein bisschen her, oder?
Das gab's mal. Ich glaube nicht, dass das
noch irgendjemand in der Version
hat, die aktuell unter Linux
lauffähig ist.
Silverlight, man. 2012.
Silverlight, das war so richtiger Schrott.
Eigentlich war Silverlight von der Idee her ganz okay.
Aber...
Und wem haben wir es zu
verdanken? Apple.
Dadurch, dass die
Flash abgeschossen haben,
wurde dann auch, und es zunehmend
uninteressanter wurde, wurde dann auch
Silverlight und dieser ganze andere Crap,
den's da noch gab.
Silverlight, wer das nicht kennt,
Silverlight war
quasi WPF
für den Browser.
Aber ohne, aber ohne
HTML und JavaScript
zu sein, sondern es war quasi eher
so eine Art Flash.
Es war quasi
WPF,
das Flash WPF
von Microsoft.
Können wir mal kurz gucken, was da...
Ja, Silverlight ist ein eingestelltes
Framework zur Ausführung von Rich Internet
Applications in einem Browser Plugin
sowie Apps in Windows Phone 7.
Ja.
Es war im Prinzip WPF.
Es war WPF und aufgebaut
als Browser Plugin so wie Flash.
Oder JavaFX.
Oder OpenLaslo.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Das war OpenLaslo.
Mit John Wick.
Ich muss mal sagen, das sieht gar nicht so kacke aus.
Das sieht aus wie ein User Interface
so aus den 90ern.
Ist das sowas wie WebAssembly?
Es ist ein zusätzliches
Third Party Plugin.
Ne, es ist nicht sowas wie WebAs...
Sowas wie Flash ist es im Endeffekt.
Sowas wie Flash.
Also vom Ansatz her ist es sowas wie Flash.
Nur, dass es am Endeffekt halt nicht wirklich
Flash-kompatibel war.
Moment, die haben das wirklich bis vor 3 Jahren
noch supportet, ja?
Ja gut, irgendwelche
Business Enterprise
Business Manager haben ja damals wahrscheinlich
Apps da drauf
entwickelt und die mussten sie dann noch für
15 Jahre supporten.
Die haben sich 2008 gedacht,
wir machen richtig einen krassen
Plan und setzen alles
auf Silverlight.
War halt ein bisschen reingeschissen, ne?
So, also wie gehen das jetzt hier weiter?
Soweit haben wir es gemacht. So, und jetzt
sollen wir was?
At all three?
ETC?
Okay, jetzt bin ich
verwirrt.
Was soll ich machen?
Chat, ich bin zu low IQ
dafür.
Was wollen die von mir?
At all three?
Encrypt
before
file system within the hooks
array. Okay.
Hooks array?
Piled systems.
Okay, was soll ich da
hinzufügen? Netconf
und Dropbear.
Okay.
Und dann soll ich meinen Boot
Krempel regeneraten.
Einfach alles regeneraten.
Und das soll jetzt funzen
oder was?
Required Crypt Device Parameter.
Ah.
Okay, Leute, ich mach mal einen Snapshot
und wir rebooten mal und gucken,
was passiert. Encrypt
ssh muss da doch rein, oder?
Recht. Ja.
Du hast recht.
Was passiert denn, wenn man nur Encrypt reinschreibt?
Ich hab die falsche VM
gesnapshottet. Hups.
Nee, hab ich nicht, oder? Oh, ich hab
die falsche VM gesnapshottet. Keck, Wade.
Lull.
Gut, dass wir drüber geredet haben, Chat.
Von wann ist der Snapshot?
Reichste
Sechste. Muss man immer
ab und zu mal löschen, weil die Dinger werden richtig groß
mit der Zeit. Keck, Wade, 4MWare.
4MWare ist halt auch ein bisschen
pp-geil, jetzt darf man den anderen Kram nicht anklicken.
Im Tag steht was von 3
Einträgen. Ja, hab ich ja gemacht.
Ich hab Netconf eingetragen, Dropbear
und Encrypt.
Wobei Encrypt hab ich jetzt absichtlich mal
nicht gemacht.
Mal gucken, was passiert. Wir haben jetzt einen Snapshot.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt
reboote. Bäm.
Es wird Zeit, das komplett von neu aufzusetzen.
Ja, mach ich auch, weil ich hab ja den Stream
gelöscht. Der hat jetzt aber
nix mit Netconf gemacht, oder?
Okay, ich hab da garantiert
irgendwas verkackt jetzt.
Also Encrypt SSH hab ich übrigens
schon mal falsch gemacht.
Das habt ihr mir ja auch grad gesagt. Ich wollte nur mal gucken,
ob es an sich noch funktioniert jetzt.
Also, machen wir das nochmal.
So, Encrypt soll durch Encrypt
SSH ersetzt werden.
Und jetzt regeneraten
wir das nochmal.
Und jetzt rebooten
wir nochmal und gucken, was passiert.
Bäm.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet...
Ach, Moment, ist da die Reihenfolge
falsch? Kommt's da auf die Reihenfolge
an? Da kommt's
bestimmt auf die Reihenfolge an.
Wie man das macht.
Also, das wird bestimmt von links
nach rechts ausgeführt.
Also, sprich
ich will zuerst
Netconf machen
und... na geil.
Ich will zuerst
Netconf machen,
dann will ich JobBear machen
und dann will ich Encrypt SSH machen.
Weil
Netconf startet meinen Netzwerkadapter,
JobBear startet SSH
und da drüber will ich dann
Encrypt SSH machen, um meine Filesystems
freizugeben. Schauen wir mal.
Reboot.
Ok, das sieht ganz gut aus.
Starting JobBear.
Passwort is required.
Achso, ich kackt.
Jetzt habe ich das eingegeben, aber der hat
nicht gestartet mit...
Ich muss nochmal rebooten.
Ich glaube, der hat sich aber keine IP geholt, oder?
Reboot.
Holt er sich schon eine IP?
Ne, ich glaube nicht.
Oder? Ping.
Ne.
Ok.
Macht er nicht.
Ich glaube, da stand auch erst im nächsten Blog
Eintrag.
Ich zeige euch aber jetzt mal was.
Ich hoffe, ich mache jetzt die Kiste nicht komplett kaputt.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Gehen wir mal von aus,
ich hätte meine Kiste irgendwie jetzt zerstört.
Können wir mal ein bisschen hier
Linux
How-to
Tutorial machen.
Also angenommen, ich hätte jetzt hier irgendwas eingetragen,
was es nicht gibt. Ich hoffe, dann bootet
mein System nicht.
Kekkewee.
So, und jetzt
neu generaten.
Das soll...
Ja, guck hier, not found.
Ich hoffe mal, das macht mein System jetzt auch
unbootable. Sonst kann ich euch nämlich
nicht zeigen, wie man das fixen kann.
Rrrrriiiiit.
Also ich hoffe,
mein System bootet jetzt nicht, Leute.
Fuck, das bootet einfach.
Easy as fuck.
Ah, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee, wie ich mein System
unbootable mache.
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Pfeifet-Idee.
Wir nehmen den Encrypt-Hook raus.
Und ohne den Encrypt-Hook
kann ich mein System nicht mehr starten.
Also mein Ziel ist jetzt, mein System
kaputt zu machen.
Und dann zeige ich euch, wie man das fixen kann,
wenn es nicht mehr bootbar ist.
So, ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
den Decrypt-Hook raus.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt
ein Linux-System
mit verschlüsselter Festplatte,
was sich nicht mehr booten lässt,
weil ich so dumm war
und
aus meinem Boot-Prozess
die Entschlüsselung der Platte rausgenommen habe.
Ich hoffe, es ist jetzt
wirklich kaputt, nachdem ich rebooted habe.
Das sieht schon besser aus.
Es hängt.
Hängen ist meistens ein schlechtes Zeichen.
Oder in dem Fall ein gutes Zeichen, wenn es kaputt ist.
Wie debuggt man
einen Kernel-Panic? Das ist schwierig.
Also anhand des Outputs
als Normalsterblicher gar nicht.
Am besten ist, du überwachst
dein System und guckst, wann das auftritt.
Also du überwachst
möglichst viel von deinem System, laufende Prozesse,
Logs,
RAM, CPU-Auslastung
und du machst dir dann irgendeinen Reim drauf.
Wenn der Kernel-Panic immer
beider gleicht, also du hast zwei Sachen.
Erstmal musst du feststellen, wann es auftritt.
Wenn du weißt, wie du es reproduzieren
kannst,
dann hast du schon mal einiges gewonnen.
Dann weißt du zum Beispiel, okay,
immer wenn ich diesen Service starte,
Crashs mit dem Kernel-Panic oder so,
oder immer wenn ich diesen Monitor anschließe,
dann kannst du das als Normalsterblicher auch
nicht fixen, aber du kannst mal bei Google gucken,
ob das schon irgendjemand anderes hatte.
Und eventuell ist es so einfach
getan mit, du machst
ein Upgrade von deinem Kernel.
Was auch unter Linux Mint und sowas
geht. Die haben ja auch verschiedene Kernel-Versionen.
Ich hatte zum Beispiel ein Problem
bei einem DVB-C Empfänger.
Der hat nicht
Kernel-Panic gecrashed,
der hat
aber hängende
Prozesse verursacht, die sich
nicht mehr beenden ließen.
Also selbst mit Kill und allem,
das war ein Bug, den habe ich dann auch
gefunden und
die einzige Variante damals
war, für meinen
DVB-C Empfänger, den ich damals
benutzt habe, einen eigenen Kernel zu kompilieren
in der neuesten Version.
Mittlerweile ist schon so lange her,
es ist überall drin.
So, also, guck mal Leute,
mein System bootet nicht mehr.
Was würde der normale
Linux-Noob denn jetzt machen?
Oder was würde
der Windows-User jetzt
machen, wenn sein System nicht mehr startet?
Neu installieren, oder?
Sich über
Microsoft aufregen oder über Linux
aufregen und neu installieren?
Nee, auf Bing suchen
kriegen die nicht mehr hin. Die würden neu installieren.
Oder
Peter von Microsoft Support anrufen.
Die würden neu installieren.
Das geht, das geht,
aber
solche Fehler kann man
tatsächlich anderweitig beheben und zwar
wenn man mit einer Linux Live CD
startet
und sich dann quasi
ich muss euch das zeigen,
ich kann das nicht gescheit erklären.
Ich zeige euch das einfach.
Wir starten jetzt mal mit einer Live CD, ok?
Wir starten mal mit einer Live CD und zwar
äh CD
Ich hoffe hier gibt es irgendwie Linux Rescue
CD oder sowas bei Netboot.
Also stellt, ok
Leute, wir machen sogar, wir machen es noch anders.
Wir machen so, wie ihr das
auch machen würdet. Ich nehme einen USB-Stick,
ok?
Ich nehme einen USB-Stick, wo ich den
Linux Rescue CD drauf habe.
Stöpsel ich jetzt an. Ups.
Fuck.
Ich habe die Verlängerung von meinem Kopf heruntergeschmissen.
Monkeys.
Ich werde entknoten, wartet mal.
So.
Excellent.
Live CDs.
Rescue CD. Haben die sowas hier überhaupt?
Letztendlich ist aber auch fast egal mit welchem System
man das macht. Ne, wir machen das anders.
Ich tue mal so,
als müsste ich jetzt den Rechner fixen
und hätte einen USB-Stick
mit einer Linux
Live CD drauf, ok?
Also ich stöpsel meinen USB-Stick an.
Blum, blum.
Machine Arch Linux, by the way.
Hatte das jetzt gecheckt. Ist das jetzt connected?
Hoffe mal.
Äh, USB-Device?
Ah ja. Ok, also.
Ich habe einen uralten USB-Stick mit ein paar
mit ein paar Linux
ISOs drauf.
So, da booten wir jetzt mal, keine Ahnung,
System Rescue.
Booten wir jetzt mal. So. Jawoll.
Alles in RAM kopieren.
Das ist gut, wir haben genug RAM.
Dann stretchen wir das mal,
dass man was sieht. So, also.
Ich hatte jetzt einen Live-USB, also
Live ISO,
Live CD, weiß ich,
von USB. Live CD von USB hört sich ziemlich
kacke an, oder? Ein Live-Linux
von USB-Stick.
Und jetzt versuchen wir unser
lokales Linux, was wir
gerade kaputt konfiguriert haben,
wieder zu fixen. Und
das ist... Mein Headset hört sich scheiße
an, wartet mal. So, hä?
Ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt mehrere Probleme
mit unserem
Linux, unserem Live-Linux.
Ne, nicht mit unserem, mit unserem lokal installierten
Linux, denn
wir haben unseren Boot-Prozess
verkonfiguriert.
Der bootet
nicht mehr. Und wir haben eine
encryptete Platte. Das heißt, damit
ich jetzt überhaupt
in irgendeiner Art und Weise mein System
fixen kann, muss ich
erst mal von der Live-CD
die Festplatte entschlüsseln,
mich dann rein-attached
in das alte System,
dort das wieder in Ordnung bringen und dann rebooten.
Das versuche ich euch jetzt mal zu zeigen.
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert, wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe. Was ist im Chat?
CPUs tacken sich runter, wenn es
zu heiß ist, ne? Vielleicht ist die
Belüftung bei dir halt einfach
irgendwie auch im Arsch, so. Aber in der
Regel überhitzen CPUs heute gar nicht mehr.
Die tacken sich runter.
Aber die Minis-Forum-PCs,
die sind bekannt dafür, dass die
also gerade unter
längerer Belastung ein bisschen zu heiß werden.
Aber einen Kernel-Panic solltest du
deswegen nicht unbedingt kriegen.
Genau, ich würde es gar nicht so im Detail schreiben.
Ich würde einfach sagen, ey, mein PC überhitzt und schaltet sich ab.
Please fix.
Wobei ich habe gehört, ich bin mir nicht
sicher, ob das stimmt, weil ich habe keine
First-Hand-Erfahrung da, aber
ich habe gehört, der Minis-Forum-Support soll
relativ useless sein.
So, also fixen wir mal unser System.
Als erstes Chat-IQ-Frage
an euch, oder
Linux-Expert-Question.
Wie
entschlüsselt man über Command-Line
eine per Lux verschlüsselte
Platte?
Weiß es jemand?
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf
so ungefähr. Ich bin mir nicht, bin mir nicht ganz
Lux, richtig? Ja?
Ja? Passt.
Passt, Chat. Wir verbinden,
wir verbinden einfach das, was ihr
Wir verbinden
das mal, was ihr geschrieben habt. Es ist
Krypt, Krypt, oh ne.
Erstmal loadkeys.de
und dann
modprobe-r pc-speaker
Wir unloaden einfach das
Kernel-Modul, dass es nicht mehr
piepsen kann. Das ist zwar die Holzhammer-Methode,
um den PC am Piepsen zu hindern,
aber die effektivste.
Einfach das Pieper, einfach das Pieper-Kernel-Modul
unloaden. Genau,
krypt-setup-lux-open ist es.
krypt-setup-lux-open
Vorher sollten wir noch gucken,
was wir für eine Disk
überhaupt...
entschlüsseln wollen. In dem Fall ist es
sdb. Und zwar
sdb2.
Man sieht es ja hier unten. Ich habe jetzt
keine Maus, um es zu zeigen.
ähm
sdb1 hat
1 Gigabyte und ist meine Boot-
Partition. sdb2
ist 650 Gig
und ist meine verschlüsselte.
Ja, man könnte auch fdisk-l
oder sowas machen, sich dann hier durchscrollen.
Da sieht man es zum Beispiel.
Guck, sdb1 ist EFI-Boot
und das andere ist die Lux-Encrypted.
Muss man sich halt rausholen.
So, und dann sagt man
krypt-setup-lux-open
Ich glaube, jetzt sagt man
einfach das Device
ne, äh
sdb2
und dann
irgendein Mountpoint, wo man hin will.
So, hier mnt.
Ne, das ist falsch.
Siehste? Ne, Moment.
mnt, das kommt später erst.
Hier, hier muss ich einfach
einen Namen angeben, wie ihr es nennen soll.
Okay, jetzt muss ich
mein Passwort für Lux eingeben.
Das ist super kompliziert. 123456 hab ich da genommen.
Während der Installation.
So, jetzt mit dem Step
wird die Festplatte entschlüsselt.
Also dieses on the fly
per Lux entschlüsseln.
Und es wird ein neues, die Festplatte ist noch nirgendswo
steht noch nirgendswo zur Verfügung.
Aber ich hab jetzt quasi ein
aus dem verschlüsselten Device
ein unverschlüsseltes Device gemacht.
Was ich jetzt mounten kann.
Jetzt kann ich dev mapper
crypt mounten nach mnt zum Beispiel.
So, und jetzt hab ich, wie ihr seht,
unter mnt hab ich
mein
Arch Linux System
von lokal.
Jetzt haben wir noch ein paar weitere Probleme.
Ich möchte jetzt das wieder rückgängig machen,
was ich eben kaputt gemacht hab.
Was ich eben kaputt gemacht hab, war
unter etc
mk
init dingsbums pc
da hab ich
da hab ich hier
encrypt rausgeschmissen.
Das heißt, ich will das eigentlich jetzt
hier encrypt
ssh will ich wieder
haben.
Dass das funktioniert.
Das geht aber an der Stelle nicht, weil
wenn ich das hier jetzt eintrage,
das ist kein Problem, aber
das reicht ja nicht. Ich muss ja
mein ganzes Boot-Image
neu generaten.
Also das einfach in der Datei
funktioniert nicht.
Das heißt, was können wir jetzt machen,
dass wir das quasi
innerhalb, im Kontext ausführen
von dem installierten Betriebssystem
auf der Platte, obwohl wir es nur gemountet haben.
chroot ist richtig, aber
chroot alleine wird es nicht tun, kann ich euch auch
zeigen. Gehen wir mal hier nach
chroot
mnt, oder was, was ist chroot minus d?
Kann man sogar sagen.
mnt
Was war noch der Unterschied zwischen minus d und
Nee, gibt's gar nicht.
chroot noch mnt
So.
Und jetzt seht ihr, wir sind
quasi in unserem
lokal installierten Linux drinnen.
Was man auch daran sieht, dass wir jetzt hier sowas wie
mk, also ich hab hier zum Beispiel meine History.
Guck, ihr seht, ich hab meine History
von meinem lokalen
installierten System hier jetzt.
Also wir sind jetzt quasi da reingeswitcht.
Nico, danke schön für den Sub.
Aber wenn wir jetzt versuchen, wir werden
jetzt versuchen, das auszuführen, kann ich euch jetzt schon
spoilern, funktioniert das immer
noch nicht. Weil
naja, es fehlen die ganzen
dynamisch gemounteten Filesystem-Dinger,
die man unter Linux dafür braucht.
Also ist proc nicht gemountet,
sys nicht gemountet, temp nicht gemountet
und
was man sonst noch so alles braucht.
So, die müssen wir jetzt auch erstmal
alle wieder mounten, dass das funktioniert.
Achso, und boot ist by the way auch
nicht gemountet. Das ist das erste,
was wir machen müssen. So.
Also als erstes mounten wir mal unsere
boot-disk nach
mnt-boot.
Also quasi relativ
zu unserem alten System.
Danach brauchen wir, und da bin ich mir
jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht sicher, deswegen muss ich
nachgucken.
chroot-proc
Ich glaub da muss man irgendwas, genau hier,
das brauchen wir.
Ja, diese drei Dinger
brauchen wir jetzt. Gibt
arch-chroot, ja aber ich bin ja nicht in dem Arch-System.
Wir machen's von Hand. Also die
diese drei Sachen brauch ich jetzt noch. Also einmal
brauchen wir hier, ich kopier mir das mal auf
den zweiten Bildschirm, dass ich nachgucken kann.
Und in wirklich, normalerweise würdet ihr
jetzt auf dem Handy nachgucken, weil ihr habt ja
keinen PC, weil euer PC gerade abgekackt ist.
So, also mount
minus t
proc und jetzt das ganze natürlich
wieder relativ
zu eurem
zu dem System in mnt.
Also wir sind ja in mnt drinnen.
Dann als nächstes das
ganze noch für sus.
Was man aus irgendwelchen Gründen
jetzt so macht, whatever.
sus
Und dann als letztes noch
def
nach def.
Und jetzt kann ich mich da rein
chrouten.
Und nun hab ich auch, wie ihr seht,
def gemountet,
boot gemountet, alles da.
Und wenn ich jetzt diesen Krempel hier ausführ,
dann funktioniert's.
Jetzt hab ich alles was ich brauche.
Jetzt bin ich quasi in
den Kontext von meinem lokalen System geswitcht
mit chrout.
Und jetzt kann ich Commandos ausführen, obwohl ich eigentlich noch
in der Live-ISO drinnen bin,
als wäre ich in meinem lokalen System.
Und dementsprechend
sollte das System
jetzt wieder funktionieren.
Wenn ich nicht irgendwelchen Mist eingetragen hab.
Hab ich irgendwelchen Mist eingetragen?
Ja
und nein, die sind ein bisschen
davon abhängig, welche kernel
Version und welche Treiber geladen sind.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
passt das.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es da nicht irgendwelche
Inkompatibilitäten
geben könnte. Wahrscheinlich.
Aber in der Regel funktioniert das.
Weil es ja die gleiche Hardware ist.
Ich mein, es kann bestimmt irgendwelche,
mir fallen jetzt keine ein, aber möglich ist es,
dass es da Probleme gibt.
Aber in der Regel geht das.
So, und wenn ich jetzt hier nicht irgendwie Mist eingetragen hab,
Encrypt, SSH, File,
was auch immer.
Hier sehe ich mein Boot-Image
und jetzt
gehe ich wieder raus, reboote die Live-CD,
ziehe den USB-Stick
ab und jetzt
booten wir mein lokales Arch und hoffen, dass es
wieder funktioniert.
Und siehe da, System
gefixt. Ein cleanes Video
auf YouTube. Das ist nichts, was die Leute bei mir auf YouTube
interessiert. Die Leute auf YouTube
wollen hören, wie ich das neue Battlefield
flame. Weil es das doch gar
nicht gibt.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Danke für den Sub.
Der Nico auch am Start.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier, Leute.
IQ increased.
Big brain time.
So.
Jetzt sind wir hier stehen geblieben bei dem Thema
booten.
So, also.
Okay, aber zumindest soweit funktioniert das Ganze
schon mal. Also wir können rebooten,
wir haben die ganzen Sachen drin, aber
wir bekommen noch keine IP
beim Booten. Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt unsere
Kernel-Parameter
anpassen. Und da muss
in die Kernel-Parameter muss rein
IP gleich DHCP.
Das heißt, ich muss meine CRUB-Config
anpassen. Und ich bin ehrlich
gesagt nicht sicher bin, wie man das macht.
Ich glaube, ich muss nach
warum nicht static IP,
weil es mehr Getippe ist.
Ich glaube, ich muss nach
defaults-crub, oder?
Steht das hier? Da bin ich mir relativ
sicher, dass ich da hin muss.
Ja, hier. EDC-Default. Aber das ist nicht
so. Das ist unter Debian auch so.
Between
Quants, CRUB, CMD-Command-Line,
Defaults.
Okay, das heißt, da muss
IP rein. Und wie
regenerate ich jetzt meine
Bootloader? So, okay.
Muss man das andere jetzt auch nochmal
ausführen? Jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt. Okay, jetzt sollte
ich, wenn ich reboote,
zumindest schon mal eine IP kriegen
und
Dropbear gestartet haben.
Sehen wir gleich, ob das
funktioniert.
Ja, das hat funktioniert. Guck mal.
145 haben wir.
Äh, was?
Hail Loading ETC
Dropbear.
Okay, Dropbear wird anscheinend nicht funktionieren.
Vermutlich.
Permission denied.
Okay, Dropbear funktioniert.
Doch.
Permission denied.
Also, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht ganz richtig.
Wie heißt diese Datei?
Ich muss mir das mal kurz aufschreiben.
Was meckert er? Drop...
Beer
Underscore ED25519
Host...
Hostkey.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Da fehlt irgendwas anscheinend.
Liegt der Hostkey in der
verschlüsselten Partition?
Ne, ich glaube, den gab's. Den gibt's
schlechtergreifend nicht.
Guck mal hier. ETC
Dropbear.
Ach, guck mal.
Es gibt ja nur einen RSA und einen
ECDSA.
Wo kommt denn der andere dann her?
Den gibt's wahrscheinlich gar nicht defaultmäßig.
Den muss ich wahrscheinlich mal von Hand
generaten.
Dann generate ich den von Hand.
Ah, nicht Root.
Dann machen wir nochmal. SSH.
Ja, machen wir's dann.
SSH
Keygen.
Dropbear.
Ja, ohne Passphrase.
Ja, selber generieren.
Nö.
Okay. So, und jetzt
kopieren wir den einfach.
CP
HomeMax.
SSH
EDC
Dropbear. So, und wie soll dieses Ding
jetzt heißen? Ich hab's mir ja aufgeschrieben.
So soll das
heißen. Ups.
Ey, what the fuck.
Okay. Generaten wir mal neu.
Jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen
Try and Error.
Und gucken.
Ja, der generated nur die zwei.
Anstatt den anderen. Alter, Pepega
stellt so, ja. Reboot.
So, gucken wir mal,
ob er jetzt eine andere Fehlermeldung hat.
Early exit string too long.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Ähm. Okay.
But why?
Okay.
Dropbear ED
No, it's not possible.
Dropbear itself. Ja, das war 2018.
Versuchst du quasi die Passwortsperre zu umgehen?
Ne.
Ich versuch, das Passwort über
SSH eingeben zu können. Nicht lokal.
Was ist denn das?
Dropbear
convert open ssh.
Aha.
Anscheinend verwenden die unterschiedliche
Worte.
Okay. Heißt.
Äh, by the way, warum
log ich mich nicht einfach so ein?
Warum log ich mich nicht einfach so ein?
Ich hab doch extra das
Passwort, das ich einloggen kann.
Ähm. Also.
Wait a minute. Was?
Dropbear. Wir gehen jetzt mal nach
etc. Okay, da gehen wir jetzt. Also was?
Convert open ssh.
Wahrscheinlich von
open ssh nach Dropbear.
Format.
Also. Und zwar.
Hostkey
nach
Ja, gut. Wir müssen das bestimmt irgendwie mal anders
nennen. 2.
Okay. Und jetzt mv
mv
dropbear ed 255
nach
So.
Ja. Ja.
Okay.
Wie sieht denn das jetzt aus? Ist das jetzt irgendwie
anders, oder?
Ah, binary stellt's. Okay.
Nice.
Warum macht man seine ssh keys in
binary?
Na gut.
Okay. Neu generaten.
Und jetzt noch mal
rrrrrrree. Nee. Noch nicht.
Doch jetzt.
Rrrrrree. Gut.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob er jetzt wenigstens
startet. Startet das verdammte
Spiel. Okay. Das sieht, das sieht ganz
gut aus. Running. Running in
background. Das hört sich gut an.
Schauen wir mal.
Hostkey verification failed.
Ja, das ergibt ja
auch Sinn. Es ist ja auch eine andere ssh
key als von open ssh.
Also sagen wir jetzt mal minus o
strict hostkey
checking no.
Ja.
Oder muss das off sein?
Off. Alter, jetzt gehen wir mal nicht
auf den Sack. Was ist jetzt das Problem?
Ach nee. Das geht.
Permission denied. Ist es vielleicht
root?
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Easy. Easy.
Easy.
Enter passphrase
for devsda2.
Es funktioniert.
Easy.
Easy. Easy.
Dann gucken wir auch mal,
ob es funktioniert. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Ich entere das jetzt
hier über ssh und
noch sehe ich nichts.
Ha.
Es funzt. Nice.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Easy. Easy.
Aber das
mit dem ssh key gefällt mir noch nicht.
Kann ich nicht einfach. Warte mal.
Eine Idee habe ich noch.
Eine Idee habe ich noch. Können wir nicht
einfach
von etc
ssh Dings hier.
Ja.
Convert.
Wir nehmen uns einfach den ssh,
den open ssh key.
Guck mal, den da. Ne, den.
Den da.
Und kopieren den nach etc
drop here
ed255
key.
Generaten das neu.
Und jetzt sollte es eigentlich einfach gehen.
Auch ohne irgendwelche blöden Warnungen.
Hoffe ich.
Guck mal mal.
Nein.
Oh.
Doch. Ich hab. Ich dachte ich habe jetzt gerade
mein Host System rebooted.
Okay. Nice.
Okay.
Okay. Schon mal gute Sache.
Ich bekomme keine Meldung mehr.
Ja. Geht.
Nice. Easy.
Dann hast du natürlich den private
Host Key auf der nicht verschlüsselten
Ja. Es gibt schlimmeres.
Dadurch ist ja nicht die Festplatte entschlüsselt.
Sondern es könnte sich nur theoretisch
irgendeiner man in the middle
ssh'n oder so. Ja.
Ja. Also sag mal so.
Vielleicht ist es nicht die allerbeste Idee.
Aber für meine Sache
daheim sollte es mal ausreichen.
So. Und jetzt kann ich mich
auch wieder mit meinem normalen
User verbinden. Und es geht
einfach, Leute. Es funzt.
Es funzt.
Guck mal. Easy, oder?
War das jetzt? Wollen wir jetzt noch mal
gucken, ob Hyperland in der VM gescheit
funktioniert? Also ich hab's letztens
ausprobiert. Da ging es nicht.
Vielleicht ist die Power
des Chats dabei,
dass es jetzt geht.
Kommen wir ins
CD mal schnell. Hyperland.
Hyperland.
Yes. Kannst du
einmal für ein nicht Arch Linux User den Vorteil
zeigen? Ich raff das nicht, warum du das machst.
Das hat mit Arch Linux oder nicht Arch Linux
nichts zu tun. Also.
Nochmal langsam.
Ich reboote die Kiste.
Okay? Also. Hier.
Die Kiste reboote ich.
Um die Kiste hier geht's.
Reboot.
So.
Ich mach jetzt mal nix.
So. Jetzt reboote die.
Und was fällt dir an der Stelle jetzt auf?
Ich
brauch an dieser Kiste eine
Tastatur und eventuell
ein Monitor, damit ich
meine Festplatte entschlüsseln kann
und weiter booten kann.
Was sehr unpraktisch ist, wenn die Kiste an
einem Ort steht, wo ich nicht richtig dran komme
oder
wo ich nicht permanent eine Tastatur
dran haben will und auch nicht jedes Mal umstecken will.
Das heißt, anstelle
jetzt lokal hier
an dieser Kiste was
eintippen zu müssen,
kann ich das Ganze auch
über SSH
machen. Von einer anderen Kiste aus.
Guck.
Ich kann quasi die Festplatte
von dieser Kiste hier
anlocken. Remote über SSH.
Ohne, dass ich
selbst an dieser Kiste
mit einer Tastatur angestöpselt sein muss.
Das heißt, die Kiste könnte jetzt
unterm Dach stehen.
Oder aber, wie ich meinen Mini-PC
hier verwenden will, hinten
am Monitor dran geschraubt.
Und ich will da eigentlich gar keine Tastatur dran haben.
Aber ich will trotzdem die Festplatte voll
verschlüsselt haben.
Guck. Und jetzt kann ich entsperren über SSH.
Du siehst, ich hab jetzt das Passwort
eingegeben über SSH.
Ich brauch jetzt ein bisschen, aber bootet ganz normal weiter.
Siehst du?
Jetzt hat er gebootet. Und jetzt
kann ich mich ganz normal verbinden auf die Kiste,
nachdem er gebootet hat.
Und alle meine Disks sind auch anlockt.
Aber erst, nachdem ich einmal per SSH auch
geht net auch TPM zum
Pff, keine Ahnung.
Das ist mir aber wurscht, ob das geht.
Pre-Shared Key
beste.
Jetzt haben wir Hyperland installiert.
Was musste man da noch alles für installieren?
Ich glaub die Mesa-Treiber musste man installieren.
Ist schon installiert.
Ähm.
Sonst noch irgendwas?
Keine Ahnung. Probieren wir das einfach mal aus.
Hyperland.
Zack.
Es ist broken as fuck.
Aber, aber es ist gestartet
in der VM.
Okay, ich kann kein Terminal starten, ich kann
keinen Launcher starten.
Ich vermute mal, der default Launcher ist einfach nicht
drauf.
Jetzt erleben wir mal Wofi.
Oh.
Das Funst, Leute. Es läuft in der VM.
Guckt mal.
Sogar mit, sogar mit Animationen
und gar nicht mal so langsam.
Aber, das gleiche, also das hat,
soweit hab ich's schon mal geschafft.
Mein nächstes Problem war, dass Hyperland
immer gecrashed ist, wenn ich Firefox
gestartet hab.
Ach ja, und,
dass es so verbuggt war,
in der VM,
dass ich noch nicht mal nen Terminal zum Laufen
bekommen hab, außer das KDE-Terminal,
witzigerweise.
Poster zu, ja, das
geht nächste Woche auch noch.
Kitty, das wollen wir nicht.
Also, das einzige, was ich zum Laufen bekommen habe,
ist tatsächlich die KDE-Konsole.
Kein Mist. Ich weiß nicht, warum,
aber was anderes hab ich nicht zum Laufen
bekommen in der VM.
Warum Hyperland statt Sway?
Weil Hyperland
Chan.
Hyper Chan.
Nee, weil Animationen und viel,
viel gehypter.
Sway tut's genauso.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich Sway
benutzen würde, da kann ich auch einfach
weiter mein i3-Setup in der VM
benutzen, was einfach funktioniert.
Wir können,
wir können gleich mal Sway starten und gucken,
ob es dann auch crasht.
Moin, Sarix.
So, also,
das ist das einzige, was ich zum Laufen bekommen hab
in der VM.
Das KDE-Terminal.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal hier config.
Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz noch die Tastatur
input
model.de
hot reload.
Das ist schon nice gemacht, muss man sagen.
Hast du 3D-Acceleration
aktiviert? Ja klar, sonst würden wir
gar nicht so weit kommen.
Ey, ich habe übrigens noch keine
VMware-Tools installiert. Vielleicht lag's ja auch
daran das letzte Mal.
Wir können mal gucken hier, lsmod grep
vmware. Doch, doch,
der hat VMware-Sachen schon installiert.
Der hat schon VMware-Sachen
installiert.
HyperCTL
Monitors
Also, ich könnte theoretisch
hier einen Monitor reinschreiben.
Virtual-1
Irgendjemand
mal kurz hier, dass ich eine ordentliche Auflösung hab.
Wie muss das aussehen mit der Auflösung?
Auto, hier.
Da muss ich mir mal ein Beispiel angucken,
wie das aussieht. Ich kann mir das nicht merken.
Äh, hallo?
Please?
Okay, dann mach's mal so hier.
Achso, okay, so muss das aussehen.
Also, dp1
ist bei mir
Virtual-1
at 60
und dann so.
Ist es denn wirklich Virtual-1?
Ey, der hat live, Leute!
Das hat gefunzt!
Also, das hat schon was. Das muss live
reloaden. So, und jetzt
habe ich das Problem, dass
wenn ich Firefox installiert...
Achso, ich zeige euch das mal. Also, Chrome
funktioniert bei mir gar nicht.
Chromium
Guts bei
mir gar nicht in der VM.
Wenn ich Chromium starten
will, ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen größer.
Wenn ich Chromium starten will,
dann sagt
er mir...
Ja.
Das zum Beispiel sagt er mir dann
...
Okay, missing X-Server.
Alles klar.
X-Wayland ist schon.
Guck.
By the way, ich habe auch keinen Mauszeiger.
Ja, stimmt, Mauszeiger
funktioniert in der VM auch nicht.
Ich habe keine Maus.
Die ist auch
kaputt. Mausanzeige
geht nicht.
Also, X-Wayland ist schon.
Und wenn ich Firefox starte, wird's
noch viel besser. Das ist also
echt nicht so richtig gemacht für die VM.
Wenn ich Firefox
starte, dann dauert
es jetzt nicht lange
und die VM crasht.
Kacke.
Also, es sieht so aus, als würde es...
Ah, okay, VM ist gecrasht.
Also, das ist
nicht so wirklich gemacht für VM,
ja? Ach ja, es ist
übrigens, die VM ist nur so halb
gecrasht. Per SSH geht es
noch, aber nicht lange.
So nach fünf Minuten
crasht es komplett.
Ah ja, und übrigens, wenn ich jetzt denke, ey, einfach Hyperland
abschießen, erstmal reagiert
Hyperland gar nicht mehr.
Und selbst wenn ich sage, Hyperland,
kill minus neun.
Oh, jetzt ist Hyperland weg.
Hyperland ist aber nicht weg, es ist immer noch da.
Übrigens, hier,
Kernelbuffer switchen geht
auch nicht mehr.
Die Kiste ist offiziell rip,
nachdem er Firefox unter Hyperland
gestartet hat. Wir können mal
X-Way starten.
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert in der VM, vielleicht geht das
besser, aber dazu
müssen wir erstmal die Kiste
neu starten, weil die ist jetzt
rip.
Die ist kaputt.
Müssen wir jetzt neu starten,
einloggen und wie startet man
X-Way? Wahrscheinlich einfach X-Way eingeben auf der
Commanderzeile, vermute ich mal.
X-Way?
Okay, das scheint zu funzen. Guck mal,
Leute, X-Way hat sogar
einen fucking Mauszeiger.
Ich bin begeistert.
Ich kann aber nichts starten,
weil
in meiner Config wahrscheinlich kein Terminal
und so drin ist.
Was machst du eigentlich? Mein System remote
über SSH anloggen, aber das haben wir schon
geschafft. Was für ein Terminal
ist default?
Was? Foodterm?
Was ist denn das schon wieder?
Warum gibt es 30
Milliarden Terminal ab?
Das sieht straight aus
wie 1995, Foodterm.
Foodterm.
Ah.
Achieved.
Wird das nicht mal weiterentwickelt?
Ach nee. Moment, das ist ja gar nicht der Typ.
Ja, also halt mal
den Funzen richtig. Mit X-Way, wir können
mal in die
X-Way
Config,
wie auch immer die X-Way
legt X-Way irgendwie eine
Default Config an oder so?
Ich habe X-Way noch nie benutzt.
Was ist denn die Default Config?
Gibt es irgendwie eine fertige Default Config,
die ich mir copy-pasten kann?
Was? ETC? Warum
ETC?
Aber die kann ich mir wahrscheinlich
rüberkopieren. ETC
X-Way, X-Way Config
und dann muss sie nach
Config X-Way, okay.
X-Way läuft nicht auf, das ist auch Wayland.
Mkdir
Config X-Way, so. Kopieren
wir das mal nach Config
X-Way.
Okay, also
Default, Output,
also was haben wir denn hier für
Mod 4 ist Windows-Taste
denke ich mal.
Das ist alles.
Preferred Terminal Emulator, machen wir mal
aktuell, nicht weil ich das KDE
Ding so sehr mag, sondern weil ich weiß, dass es drauf
ist und funktioniert. W-Menu.
Nee, nee.
Fuck.
Ja, das können wir dann immer noch
anpassen. Das einzige, was wir jetzt mal
anpassen ist Output.
Output, X-Way Configuration
Output.
Äh.
Äh, what the fuck?
Kann ich jetzt einfach sowas reinschreiben wie
Virtual 1
und dann geht
das? Hat X-Way auch Hot Reload?
Nee, anscheinend
nicht, ne?
Ähm.
By the way, wie quitte
ich, wie quittet
man, wie quitt?
Wie exited man?
Das ganze?
Mod Shift
E. Okay, probier mal aus.
Mod
Shift E. Ah, okay.
Wie E3 im Endeffekt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ne ordentliche Auflösung, nice.
Wir haben ein Terminal.
Wenn auch super hässlich.
Und jetzt müssen wir noch die
Tastatur
Äh, ja, die hab ich,
das hab ich noch hier offen, das soll ich mal zumachen.
Machen wir, passen wir mal noch kurz
die Tastatur an.
Okay, das läuft in der Tat
deutlich besser.
Kann X-Way irgendwelche
Animationen in Wayland?
So Transparenz oder so irgendwas?
X-Way ist quasi
E3, nur für Wayland.
Das ist fast
1 zu 1 E3 Clone.
Input. Ups.
Ah ja.
Input.
Äh.
Wie wärs mit ne
Konfiguration für die Tastatur?
Okay, viel interessanter ist,
ob jetzt,
Loadkeys funktionieren natürlich nicht.
Viel interessanter ist, ob Firefox hier drin
auch wieder das System zum Abkacken bringt.
Oder nicht.
Das werden wir gleich sehen.
Also in, X-Way läuft
echt ganz brauchbar mittlerweile.
Unser letzter Versuch mit Wayland in der
VM war kompletter Reinfall.
Da konnte man teilweise noch nicht mal Fenster richtig
resizen. Also das ging schon,
das ging schon ganz gut klar.
Dann suchen wir nochmal.
X-Way Input Layout.
All in One oder
CPU Luftkühler. Ich hab
tatsächlich
zum ersten Mal mit meinem letzten
PC eine
All in One Wasserkühlung gekauft.
Aber das würde
ich nicht unbedingt empfehlen. Das würde ich
nur wenns halt Sinn macht.
Wenn du ne CPU
hast, die du nicht gescheit gekühlt bekommst
mit konventionellen
Luftkühler.
Ansonsten würde ich auch immer
einen Luftkühler vorziehen.
So, wie sieht das hier mit Input
aus jetzt?
Dreh durch mit der englischen Tastatur.
Hier so.
Layout.de
Den Rest können wir
freilassen. Oh Mann, ich kann
nicht mehr. Okay, ich hoffe,
dass jetzt
das Ganze,
wenn ich es jetzt neu starte,
mit deutschem Tastatur
Layout drauf kommt.
Ja, nice.
Okay, funzt.
Funzt denn jetzt auch Chrome?
Chromium?
Ne.
Das ist in der VM immer
noch kaputt, Leute. Ich sag's euch.
Das ist immer noch pro...
Ist einfach gecrashed.
Das ist einfach kaputt.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
das mit Wayland in der
VM jemals was wird,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich guck mir das seit Jahren immer
mal wieder an, aber
funktionieren tut es...
Also, es hat noch nie funktioniert.
Sway in libvirtkvm.
Ja, das ist schön.
Das bringt mir halt in dem Konstellation
nix. Das ist halt
kaputt. Wir können noch mal
die VMware Tools installieren.
Äh, die
bringen uns aber nur was für
Copy-Paste.
Nicht für die Grafikausgabe.
Wow.
Ey, geh weg.
Schrecklich.
Das ist blöd, wenn Chrome...
Also, wenn Chrome
dein Desktop crasht, ist irgendwas faul, oder?
Man könnte jetzt sagen,
Firefox größer Chrome, aber
ich möchte doch schon
meine normal
benutzten Programme öffnen können, ohne dass
der Desktop crasht.
Wie funktioniert eigentlich Twitch?
Nur Twitch wissen.
Also, es funktioniert schon mal nicht über...
Nee, RTMP benutzt du bei Twitch nur, um
es zu Twitch zu senden.
RTMP im Browser funktioniert ja nicht.
Ach so.
Nee.
Also, Twitch hat verschiedene Eingangsserver
auf der Welt. Die kannst du auch in jedem...
den meisten Stream-Clients
auswählen. Die gibt's auch bei Twitch auf der Webseite
zu sehen. Ja, in Frankfurt gibt's, glaub ich,
sogar drei Stück mittlerweile.
Da schickst du per RTMP deinen Videostream hin.
So. Dann...
verarbeitet Twitch, wie
auch immer, intern irgendwie
deinen Stream.
Reencode den vielleicht, falls
der nicht in einem Format ist, dass ihn alle empfangen
können. Und dann
wird der ausgeliefert für Viewer
über zum größten Teil HLS.
Das ist
Livestreaming über HTTP. Du kriegst quasi immer
einzelne Video-Chunks gesendet.
Doch mittlerweile
geht das... Mittlerweile können die
mehrere Sachen, die können nicht nur HLS, die können auch
mehr. Aber wie das intern
genau funktioniert, keine Ahnung.
Also, wenn mich ein Login-Manager dafür
bräuchte, wär schon sehr weird.
Man sieht auch überhaupt keine...
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Sway... Wieso mach ich das? Sway?
Sway
Segmentation
Vault
Chromium. Aha!
Vor drei Jahren. Ich... Leute,
das ist halt so die typische Sache bei
dem Wayland-Entwicklungs-Kram.
Die sagen dann immer, ja, benutzt eine Version mit
Wayland-Support. Leute,
es muss auch der alte Kram funktionieren.
Und mittlerweile hat er das, glaub ich, schon.
Aber Wayland ist einfach echt
keck-double-U. Also, in der... Man muss
ja auch sagen, der Fairness heißt aber, in der
VM ist das ziemlicher Schrott.
Natürlich, die schieben sich
aber seit Jahren schon
die...
die Schuld hin und her. So, ah,
das ist der VMware-Treiber. Ah, das ist Wayland.
Das ist mir als User
scheißegal.
Schau the Logs. Ja, das würde ich machen, wenn da nicht mal ein ganzes
Ding crasht. I think the
real solution here is use Firefox.
Ey, das ist doch... Ey, das ist ein absoluter
Witz, oder? Das mag ja
sein, dass das native ist und besser funktioniert,
aber das ist ja jetzt nur
ein Symptom, dass Chrome nicht geht. Das wird
wahrscheinlich alle anderen X-Programme auch
betreffen. Keck weh.
Also, Leute, ich glaube, ohne
Scheiß, das mit... Das mit Wayland
in... Oh, Alter. So.
Das mit... Das mit
Sachen in der VM kannst du knicken.
Das... Das hier... Das ja, das Linux-Desktop
sieht... Sollen wir mal andere X-Pro...
X-Software starten und gucken, was passiert?
Ich mein, Chrome ist schon die Hardcore-Variante.
Wie sieht's mit X... X-Eyes
aus? Das ist aber...
Das ist 100 Pro und ein Problem
im Zusammenhang mit den... Mit den VMware-Treibern.
100 Pro. X-Eyes.
X-Eyes crashes. Also, jetzt nur
mal so... Ich zeige euch mal die absolute
High-End-Anwendung X-Eyes, Leute.
Habe ich noch nicht mal installiert.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Da können wir reingucken.
X-Eyes. Passt mal auf.
Also, das geht
natürlich nicht. Das ist... Das ist
way too advanced
für Wayland.
So was hier anzuzeigen.
Das ist
zu aufwendig. Ja?
Zwei weiße Kreise
und schwarzer
Hintergrund. Viel
zu heftig.
Ähm...
...
Okay, den Stacktrace habe ich mir
noch nie angeguckt.
XI is not, doch XI is crashed bei mir auch.
Das stimmt.
Wisst ihr, das Problem, was ich
bei dieser Sache auch sehe, ist,
dass, wenn man mal ganz ehrlich ist,
das ist eh schon extrem Nische
Linux Desktop.
Und es ist durch Wayland
und die 30 verschiedenen Desktop-Environments
und mit Wayland ist es noch schlimmer geworden,
weil Wayland hier explizit sagt,
sie sind quasi kein,
ja, wie heißt das?
Sie sind kein Windows-System,
sie sind ein reiner,
eine reine
Schnittstelle quasi
zur Grafikkarte und zum Input.
Das ist ja Wayland im Endeffekt.
Dementsprechend muss jeder
Desktop, nennen wir es mal,
seinen eigenen
Kram
implementieren.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
dass du nur noch
Nische, Nische, noch Nischiger
unterwegs bist. Du bist Linux Desktop
eh schon Nische as fuck.
Dann bist du
Wayland, Linux Desktop, schon mal
Nische as fuck. Darauf dann,
wie gesagt, komplett
reimplementiert, muss das ja
alles werden von den ganzen Desktop-Environments.
Darauf dann beispielsweise
Gnome oder
Sway oder Hyperland.
Das heißt, du bist ein Nischen-User
in einer eh schon existierenden
Nische dessen Nische.
Und das wird immer schlimmer.
Buffer-API korrekt.
Ja, VMware-Treiber brauchen
wahrscheinlich. Ja, geh ich auch mal von aus.
For GPU-Driver
and Wayland to be
they must support the same
Buffer-API.
There are two main APIs.
GBM und EGL.
Ah, ja, alles klar.
Gnome macht mal wieder ihren eigenen Shit, das ist klar.
Aber wie gesagt,
ist ja da der VMware-Treiber, also insofern.
Also was wir tatsächlich noch mal machen
könnten ist,
also was wir theoretisch noch mal machen könnten
ist,
ja, was?
Wichslgcsel.
Okay, alles klar.
Das wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Was wir nochmal machen könnten ist.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt machen?
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas ist mir gerade eingefallen.
Das geht nicht.
Ach so, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was ich
machen wollte.
Ja, wir können die VR mal ausschalten.
Und mal gucken...
Ne, ich bin ja auch schon halb so alt wie der,
also insofern.
Wir können mal Accelerate 3D Graphics ausmachen
gucken was dann passiert also das ist nix wie ich das laufen lassen möchte weil es dann software
gerendert wird wahrscheinlich abfang langsam ist aber wenn es jetzt läuft ohne 3d acceleration
dann ist es 100 prozent der vmware grafiktreiber und auch wenn es nicht geht dann ist es immer noch
ziemlich sicher der vmware grafiktreiber wir könnten noch mal wir könnten auch mal eine
git version von sway installieren das ist ja ohne 3d acceleration geht schon mal gar nix also pech
gehabt also dass uns schon mal an zu wenig ram kann es auf jeden fall auch nicht liegen weil
wir haben acht gigabyte mal vier nehmen das sollte auch reichen vier gigabyte grafikspeicher ja das
kann man so nicht sagen ich will ich will x nicht gut reden ja x ist ein uraltes ding was keiner
mehr versteht und von der architektur darunter her überhaupt nicht geeignet ist für die aktuelle zeit
die also x ging ja damals als x entwickelt wurde also x
x 11 beziehungsweise das unten drunter jetzt ist es x org für was x free irgendwas aber als
x entwickelt wurde ging man ja davon aus dass die zukunft des desktops quasi terminal server
sind also sprich ein fetter host der irgendwo steht und die anderen leute korrekten sich dann
von irgendwelchen arbeitsplatz rechnern und die eigentliche anwendung läuft da drauf und die
grafik ausgabe geht darüber das ist ja von der architektur komplett dämlich heute das findet ja
insofern ist x sicherlich auch nicht gut aber du hast diese ultra fragmentierung unter x nicht
weil alles zumindest auf x aufgesetzt hat ja ob jetzt gtk cute oder was auch immer das gui gemalt
hat war erst einmal egal bei wayland ist es ja so dass es quasi eine protokoll definition gibt
und hyperland implementiert das sway implementiert das klub implementiert das aber das heißt nicht
dass es miteinander was irgendwie zu tun hat also es kann durchaus
bugs geben nur unter kde und nicht und der highland weil die irgendwas anders implementiert haben das
war mit x nicht so weil natürlich hast du kde bugs und iii bugs das war aber auf anwendungs-
ebene so was habe ich jetzt bin ich war noch 0 xk
ok crash
ich glaube
es funktioniert das war bereits das war alles okayTV
okayTV
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir da großartig was dran machen können.
Da können wir, glaube ich, nichts dran ändern.
Ich meine, wir könnten noch...
Ah, das sind X-Octrivers, das bringt man sich nicht.
Wir könnten noch eine neue Version von Sway installieren.
Sway Git könnten wir noch installieren.
Macht eigentlich wenig Sinn.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwas ändert.
Ja, Patrick sehe ich genauso.
Wenn es danach geht...
Ich würde auch in dem Fall Mac nehmen.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil Mac Linux, aber sagen wir mal Unix-artig genug ist,
dass es dich nicht abfuckt wie Windows.
Du kannst einfach ein ordentliches Terminal nehmen, Command-Line-Tools und in der Regel,
vor allem mit dem Nix-Package-Manager, hast du jetzt mittlerweile ja auch Zugriff auf sehr, sehr viele Packages für macOS.
Und, also mit Homebrew auch schon, aber mit dem Nix-Package-Manager noch mehr.
Und du hast, wenn du, sagen wir mal so, Stable-GUI- und Graphics-Zeugs brauchst,
hast du es halt.
Und du hast es halt unter macOS.
Ich würde für kommerzielle Sachen im Leben nicht anfangen, hier irgendwas unter Linux, Wayland und X zu basteln.
Im Leben nicht.
Bei Spielen noch vielleicht, weil Spiele das in der Regel relativ wenig juckt.
Die malen eh alles selbst.
Die brauchen im Endeffekt irgendeinen OpenGL oder einen Vulkan-Kontext in irgendein Viereck, wo sie reinmalen dürfen und das reicht ihnen dann.
Aber für Anwendungen im Leben, das würde ich mir nicht geben.
So, jetzt haben wir Sway, die Git-Variante von Sway laufen, die ist neuer.
Aber ich wette mit euch, X-Eyes, oh, die ist so neu, dass es direkt beim Starten schon crasht.
Es ist direkt beim Starten broken.
Okay, sind wir mal nett, geben wir ihm nochmal ne Chance, rebooten wir nochmal.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, was das Wetter macht, ob ich vielleicht noch ne Runde radeln gehe gleich.
Sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus.
Keine Errors mehr, ja.
Oh, es startet gar nicht mehr.
User bin Sway, success.
Huge success.
I'm taking a note here, huge success.
Es ist broken, nice.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Also Sway-Git ist schon mal komplett kaputt.
Okay.
Was macht Hyperland in der Zwischenzeit so?
Ah, nice, Hyperland crasht immer noch mit Firefox.
Bist du eigentlich bald ready für den Iron Man? Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ganz bestimmt.
Oh, guck mal, noch läuft Hyperland. Leute, es ist noch nicht gecrasht.
Ah, jetzt ist es gecrasht, okay.
Das funzt erstklassig in der VM.
Richtig nice.
Das wird, ohne Scheiß soll ich sagen, das wird mit Wayland das Quiz, das kannst du vergessen.
Zumindest im Kontext von der VM.
Deswegen ist ja eigentlich auch die Sache, weswegen wir das heute ausprobiert haben, dass ich vielleicht mal was anderes zum Arbeiten verwenden kann als meine Linux-VM.
Also, mit Arbeiten. Wenn ich irgendwas mache, was ich nicht in Windows machen will, nehme ich mit dem Mini-PC, den ich hier am Start habe.
Aber aktuell sieht es nicht so aus. Es ist immer noch sehr eklig.
Wobei das Stream über Moonlight zu Sunshine, die Namen, Alter, echt erstaunlich gut und lackfrei funktioniert.
Suchen wir da einmal.
Sway VM.
Oh ja.
Was soll ich selecten?
Ups, das ist das falsche. SSH.
Ah, Moment, der sitzt gerade im Boot.
Den großen Arch-Setup-Stream, den gibt es, sobald ich in irgendeiner Art und Weise da ein Setup drauflaufen habe, was ich so verwenden will.
Das wird noch ein bisschen dauern.
Was soll ich, das soll ich installieren?
Warum soll ich Xorg-Drivers installieren, damit Sway in Wayland gescheit funktioniert?
Das erscheint mir irgendwie nicht ganz zielführend zu sein, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wir machen es mal.
Vieles Linux, man.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich noch eine Runde Fahrrad fahren gehe.
Also, eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock.
Ich war schon zwei Stunden unterwegs heute.
Ah, Moment.
Wir müssen wieder den alten Sway installieren.
Das Sway aus Git tut ja nicht.
Was?
Okay.
Sway.
Alter.
Geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Mod Pro minus R PC Speaker.
Hau ab.
Sway. Git. Yes.
Alter, was?
Der Kram wird nicht richtig entfernt, oder wie?
Force.
Ne.
Wie geht das jetzt?
Kann man irgendwie Force sagen?
Dass er das alles überschreibt?
Pac-Man Force.
Minus Minus Override.
What the fuck, Alter?
Override.
Muss bei Minus hinter Minus S, ne?
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Ist mir auch zu dumm jetzt.
Gibt's das nicht mehr?
Also, Minus Minus Force ist nicht mehr.
Okay, Force Override ist nicht mehr erlaubt.
Warum auch immer.
So, ein verkacktes Hour Package,
was die Hälfte nicht deinstalliert.
Und dann...
Moment, man muss Backslash Sternchen.
Also, wie obskur willst du es denn eigentlich noch machen?
Ah, das funzt jetzt, oder was?
Okay, alles klar.
X, A, S.
Okay, ich geb's auf.
Kein Wayland in der VM.
Ist schon ein bisschen kacke.
Wem auch immer man jetzt da die Schuld
in die Schuhe schieben kann, im Zweifelsfall
wahrscheinlich VMware.
Aber die Linux Desktop Fragmentierung
und
Nischenanwendung in der Nischenanwendung
trägt mit Sicherheit dazu bei.
Weil ganz ehrlich, VMware kann sich das ja auch nur
erlauben, weil es fünf Anwender auf der Welt
gibt, die diese Kombination vielleicht verwenden wollen.
Wären es fünf Millionen Anwender, dann
gibt's deutlich mehr Probleme.
Für VMware, wenn's nicht gehen würde.
Wobei VMware auch auf vieles scheißt.
Spätestens seit es Broadcom ist.
Aber wir haben unser Ziel für heute erfüllt.
Wir können es
Remote Unlocken.
Guck hier nochmal. Beweis, dass es
funktioniert. System startet.
System möchte
Passwort eingegeben haben.
So, und ich kann
über SSH Remote
die Disk entlocken.
Und es bootet weiter.
Ja, ich sag ja vielleicht,
fünf Leute oder so.
Hast du mal mit Proxmox in der VGPU
getestet? Wäre spannend, ob's dann...
Ach, dann wird das wahrscheinlich funktionieren. Da geh ich mal von aus.
Aber es ist halt ein Setup, was mir wenig bringt.
Haben die das erfunden, um RGB zu komprimieren?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, auf was du anspielst.
So.
Dann würde ich sagen, das hier weg. Power off.
Bam. Open Directory.
Hier kommt's weg.
Open Directory.
Arch Test, by the way.
Auch weg. Zack.
Empty Recycle Bin.
Bam. Weg ist es.
Geht das über Hyper-V?
Keine Ahnung, das werd ich aber auch nicht
ausprobieren.
Das werd ich bestimmt nicht ausprobieren.
Aber Proxmox probieren wir auf der Mini-PC
Kiste nochmal aus. Das ist ne gute Idee.
Einfach nur just for fun.
Ob das... Wie das so funktioniert.
Das ist kein Setup, was ich benutzen will.
Aber... Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Wofür ist der neue Mini-PC?
Eigentlich hab ich den geplant
als...
als Alternative hier zu
meiner Linux-Desktop-VM.
Und ich will's genauso verwenden
wie hier.
Ich will einfach auf meinem zweiten
Desktop ein Fullscreen-Windows haben.
Fertig.
Mit der VM ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Von der Performance her ist die VM...
Also...
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen,
es ist Native-Performance.
Aber...
Es fühlt sich an wie Native-Performance.
Das einzige, wo man das merkt,
ist, wenn man, ja, beispielsweise
YouTube-Videos in der VM abspielen will,
dann ist halt die CPU-Last
relativ hoch, weil dort
keine Grafikkarte drin ist mit
Video-Decodern.
Aber gehen tut das auch.
Und...
Das VM-Setup hat halt
einige Vorteile, ja.
Erstens integriert sich super in meinen...
Windows...
Ich meine, ich mache 90% der Sachen,
wenn ich was mache, unter Linux.
Aber trotzdem lässt sich
Linux unter Windows besser virtualisieren
als Windows unter Linux.
Zumindest in der Art und Weise, wie ich's benutzen will.
Und...
Du hast halt im Endeffekt schon ein paar
Vorteile dadurch.
Du hast relativ easy Zugriff auf
Linux-System auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Kannst einfach switchen.
Ja, es ist super integriert.
Wenn du mal wieder da am rumbasteln bist.
Und Performance
ist auch vollkommen nice.
Copy-Paste funktioniert auch ohne Probleme.
Also ich kann jetzt hier hingehen und keine Ahnung,
das da kopieren und hier einfügen.
So. Und das nachzubauen,
beispielsweise,
wenn man hier nebendran einen Mini-PC stehen hat,
ist gar nicht so einfach.
Man kann über Sunshine streamen.
Das funktioniert. Ja, das VM-Setup ist auch
deutlich angenehmer. Aktuell zumindest noch.
Man kann über Sunshine streamen.
Der Sunshine-Stream
ist echt nicht schlecht. Der funktioniert
relativ gut und relativ latency-free.
Aber da hast du Probleme mit Soundausgabe.
Teilweise.
Ja, und generell auch
auf Native-Kiste ist Wayland und
Hyperland jetzt bisschen pain in the ass.
Wie viele Ressourcen ich
meiner Linux-VM zugewiesen hab? Viel zu viele.
Ich glaub 24 GB
RAM
und 8 CPU-Kerne.
Das läuft auch
deutlich weniger gut.
Die idlet im Endeffekt
ja nur rum.
Du kannst ja auch ohne Probleme
ähm, nur
3 CPU-Kerne
zuweisen und 4 oder 8 GB
RAM. Das geht genauso gut.
Bei mir ist es halt so, also
ich hab absichtlich so viel RAM, weil
ich zum Beispiel mal ganz gerne
sagen wir mal hier
Rider offen hab
und
warum ist die
Schrift so weird?
Rider offen hab, dann hab ich hier
GoLand auf und bei dem anderen hab ich noch
eh, Visual Studio Code auf.
Oh, und hier noch Visual Studio Code
auf. Und da siehst du schon,
da braucht auch, und das liegt nicht daran,
dass es eine VM ist, das braucht
einfach so viel Leistung, ja,
und so viel, und so viel RAM.
Und wenn ich hier noch ein bisschen Frontend-Zeug
aufhab, dann wirst du halt sehen,
dann haben wir jetzt auf einen Schlag,
also nicht nur, dass das Ding ultra viel
CPU-Last gerade verursacht, was aber gleich wieder runtergeht,
was gleich wieder runtergeht,
nachdem der ganze Kram geladen ist. Also sobald
der Kram geladen ist, geht's, geht's wieder runter.
Das dauert, das dauert
jetzt kurz. Die wurden auch gerade
geupdatet, die Software zum ersten Mal und so, das
passt schon. So, guck jetzt ist wieder alles
gut. Aber trotzdem,
jetzt haben wir ordentlich RAM belegt,
ja.
Das braucht schon ein bisschen was.
Jetzt ist die CPU wieder super idle.
Ich glaub du hast dich einfach schon an ein paar
Sachen gewöhnt.
Fängt ja schon an, dass Wofi als App-Launcher
sich overlayt.
Mehrfach.
Und man das selbst skripten muss, dass es das nicht tut.
Ja, wird es, wird das auch.
Hyperland ist aber echt ganz nice.
Also von den ganzen
Wayland-Dingern ist das das erste, was
mich anspricht, so dass ich's mal ausprobieren
wollte. Ich hab mir auch schon überlegt,
ob ich's nicht einfach so mache, dass ich im Endeffekt
hier meine, ähm,
meine Capture-Card starte
und im Fullscreen
den auf dem zweiten Desktop anzeige.
Dann hast du aber auch wieder das Problem,
Maus-Input,
das wird sich noch mit irgendwas wie Synergy
lösen lassen und sowas, ja.
Aber dann fängt's da schon an wieder eklig zu werden.
Also ganz
ehrlich, ich hab bis jetzt noch kein Setup
gefunden, was
so easy funzt wie
meine VM im Fullscreen auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Und was auch einfach funktioniert, ja.
Es wäre halt cool, würde
das ganze Wayland-Zeug besser in der VM
laufen, dann würde ich's auch benutzen,
aber macht's halt nicht.
Geiler Background. Ach ja, zum Thema
Background. Falls ihr der
Background oder falls euch der Background gefällt,
mach mal hier den ganzen Krempel
zu. Der wechselt übrigens auch öfters,
der Background, der wechselt alle, alle Viertelstunde.
Es gibt eine ganze
Sammlung bei mir auf GitHub
von den Pepo-Backgrounds
für jede Tageszeit.
Ach ja, VM-Switch ist auch so,
so nervig.
Es ist alles eklig, es ist alles
eklig im Vergleich zu zweiter Desktop und
ne VM im Fullscreen.
Da VM-Switch hast du das Problem, Keyboard ist nicht geshared.
Das erste, was mir einfällt, du hast
für alle unterschiedlichen Tageszeiten
macht der Pepo
unterschiedliche
Dinger. Irgendwann putzt er sich auch noch
die Zähne und ihr träumt da
Zeug und guckt
Channels,
die irgendwie gerade keine Videos machen.
Ja. Es gibt sogar
in dem Repo,
Spice kannst du auch vergessen.
Außerdem
geht das nur, wenn du schon unter Linux bist.
Will ich ja nicht. Host ist ja
Windows. Ja, hast du
nen KVM-Switch, das dann Keyboard geshared ist?
Äh, nicht Keyboard, Clipboard.
Wüsste nicht, wie den KVM-Switch
Shared Clipboard machen soll.
Guck mal, wir haben da sogar einen.
Hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Das stimmt!
Warum putzt der Pepo
eigentlich nicht seine Zähne morgens, sondern
nur abends?
Der sollte eigentlich auch morgens die Zähne putzen.
Vielleicht hat der Rackman ja Zeit
und kann dem Pepo auch noch eine Zahnbürste
morgens in die Hand drücken.
Ja, da brauchst du wieder ne extra Software, um Clipboards
zu sharen. Gibt's ja auch ein paar Sachen.
KDE Connect hab ich übrigens nicht gecheckt,
ob das nur zwischen Desktop
und Phone ist, oder auch
zwischen Desktops funktioniert.
Und es gibt noch ein Skript, dass das alle Viertelstunde
den Background ändert, je nach
Tageszeit.
Aber das ist alles schon wieder gefuddelt.
KDE Connect hab ich auch ausprobiert.
KDE Connect hat bei mir sich die Desktops
untereinander nicht gefunden.
Kann auch sein, dass ich irgendwelche Packages vergessen hab.
Alles bisschen Painschamp.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich werd wahrscheinlich
auf ewig auf meiner
zweiten Desktop mit 4M hängenbleiben, weil's
einfach funktioniert.
Unter Windows geht der Hintergrund
natürlich auch, das sind ganz normale Bilder.
Das Bash-Skript
zum Ändern der Hintergründe funktioniert
nicht unter Windows, nee, aber
war auch nicht notwendig.
Die Hintergründe gehen unter Windows,
das sind ganz normale PNG-Bilder.
Ja, 3D-Sachen in der 4M
ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Auch Animationen und sowas.
Weil die irgendwie nicht alles unterstützen.
Und 4M, wer auch irgendwie keinen Bock hat, da dran zu arbeiten.
Es geht erstaunlich gut
in der 4M, wenn's geht.
Also wenn alles
unterstützt wird in der 4M, ist 3D-Performance
gar nicht schlecht.
Oder allgemein, ja, Beschleunigungs-
performance gar nicht schlecht. Wenn's nicht unterstützt wird,
crashen die Programme halt oder haben Klitsche.
Das heißt, das ist nicht wirklich gut.
Aber für mein Gedöns hier,
bisschen IDE
und Web-Entwicklung und Mikrocontroller-
Entwicklung, Server-Anwendung,
Command-Line-Tools und so, dafür ist es top.
Ja genau, das ist richtig.
Wenn's geht, läuft's relativ
gut, aber vieles geht halt nicht.
Ihr gibt es ja schon, aber das wird
von 4M per Workstation nicht unterstützt.
Hätte 4M per Workstation die Möglichkeit,
eine Grafikkarte durchzureichen?
Das wäre natürlich
cool, da müsstest
ihr nur überlegen, wie du das mit dem Video-Output
wieder machst, aber können sie nicht.
Zumindest nicht unter Windows.
Ja, glaub ich auch nicht,
dass 4M mit richtigen Wayland-Support ordentlich
Das liegt
aber halt auch daran, weil 4M sich das leisten
kann. Das ist, weil Wayland
und der jeweilige Desktop auch noch
das ist halt, Linux-Desktop ist
eh schon Nische as fuck.
Dann Wayland ist
nochmal noch mehr Nische und dann darauf
noch Hyperland oder sowas.
Was willst du sagen?
Warum sollte 4M was machen für 5 User
auf der Welt?
Da ist der Rage gar nicht groß
genug, das interessiert die überhaupt nicht.
Man könnte jetzt
sagen, ja gut, weil sie ein gutes
Virtualisierungs-Produkt machen wollen, aber das geht 4M
doch schon lange am Arsch vorbei.
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, ich sag euch,
wann das Jahr des Linux-Desktops war.
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops war so ungefähr
2009 rum,
als Ubuntu angesagt war
mit Compits.
Das war
Next Level Linux-Desktop.
Mit Würfeln und
abbrennbaren Fenstern und das wichtigste
Wobbly Windows.
Geht das eigentlich für Hyperland?
Wobbly?
Wobbly Windows.
Es wurde anscheinend nie gemerged, Wobbly Windows für Hyperland.
Übrigens, dass
man sieht, dass das tatsächlich
relevant ist, was ich gesagt habe, mit Nische
von der Nische, mit der Nische.
Ich wette mit euch, wenn ich
jetzt ein aktuelles
keine Ahnung, Ubuntu installiere,
mit einem Gnome drauf, was
übrigens auch defaultmäßig unter Wayland läuft,
auch in der 4M, da starten
x-Programme wahrscheinlich.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir da einfach
funktionieren.
Und da siehst du das Problem, dass
die Implementierung der ganzen Wayland-Protokolle
halt je nach Desktop-Umgebung und
nach, ich weiß nicht, wie man es genau nennt,
Wayland,
Composite-Implementierung
unterschiedlich ist.
Und das Problem hat sie zumindest unter x nicht.
x war immer scheiße.
Aber wenn es ging, dann ging es.
Wie Wobbly Windows aussieht, Moment.
Das muss ich dir jetzt zeigen.
Da ist das richtige massive
Bildungslücke, wer kein Wobbly Windows kennt.
Wobbly Windows.
Will er das vielleicht mal zeigen heute noch?
Ja.
Hier, Wobbly Windows.
Da ist es, da hast du es.
Beste.
Der beste Effekt.
Leider ist das überhaupt nicht mehr so
drin heute.
Beste war das, Wobbly Windows.
Das war das Ja
des Linux-Desktops.
Wayland ist in ganz vielen Fällen
broken. Und das
geile ist ja, dass man nicht mal
wirklich sagen kann, Wayland ist
broken, sondern man kann wahrscheinlich
sagen, die jeweilige
Implementierung der Wayland-Protokolle
deiner gewählten
Implementierung sind
broken.
Das ist halt auch schon wieder ein bisschen
problematisch alles.
Weil du dann Wayland-Fehler
hast, in Anführungszeichen, die keine Wayland-Fehler
sind, sondern halt wirklich dann
Hyperland- oder Gnome-Fehler.
Aber das hilft alles nichts,
weil es die E50-User
nur noch weiter unterteilt.
Warum sollte VMware kehren
dafür, wenn irgendwie
drei Hyperland-User auf der Welt
sich über irgendwas beschweren, was in
der Welt nicht geht? Das geht VMware
komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Leider.
Ich sehe auch ein bisschen das Problem,
wie bei vielen größeren Projekten,
es gibt auch gute Gegenbeispiele,
bei Wayland sehe ich
ein bisschen das Problem, dass sie super
langsam mit allem sind, was man so als
Außenstehender mitverfolgt,
dass sie super langsam sind mit allem
und dass die kleinsten Sachen,
die kleinsten Änderungen
über
Monate
zerdiskutiert werden
und da der quasi, der
weiß ich nicht, wie man das auf Deutsch sagen soll,
mit
seitenlangen Aufsätzen
über grundsätzliche
Sachen, ob
Icons jetzt dieses Pixel-Format
haben sollten oder andere,
mit Aufsätzen übertroffen
wird, mehrere A4-Seiten
lang, dann hast du Merch-Requests,
die sind 160,
180 Seiten lang,
mit Romanen drinnen,
über
Grundsatzdinger,
das Pixel-Format
war schon immer scheiße,
wir brauchen jetzt das Byte an der Stelle und so,
aber wie es der ursprüngliche
Implementierer gemacht hat, das funktioniert
unter Gnome nicht, aber Gnome ist eh egal,
weil Gnome würde es eh nicht implementieren,
die Gnome-Leute sind immer die geilsten
in diesen Diskussionen, die Gnome-Leute,
die kommen, also zumindest,
wenn ich mir irgendwelche Wayland-Sachen angucke,
die Gnome-Leute, die kommen in die Diskussion rein,
und sagen, nein, nein, nein, das kann man
so nicht implementieren, aber
letztendlich ist es auch egal, weil Gnome
wird es eh nie adapten.
Ja, dann scheiß doch drauf, Alter!
Das sind eh die geilsten, ne?
Wayland-RS, ne?
Ich glaube, der Zug
ist abgefahren. Du kannst
unter Linux nicht sagen,
ja, wir bleiben einfach bei X,
also das kannst du schon machen,
aber du wirst immer, immer,
immer zunehmend
mehr Probleme kriegen,
und Wayland
kannst du auch nicht benutzen,
weil vieles nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ich glaube, wir sind, was Linux
Desktop angeht,
es ist ja nicht ganz korrekt,
zu sagen, Linux Desktop,
also quasi Linux Display
Server, und selbst da kommen jetzt
die Wayland-Leute schon an, und sagen,
Wayland ist aber kein Display Server.
Ähm, ein bisschen
in der Sackgasse, was das angeht.
Ich glaube, für so eine Technik
ist es manchmal gar nicht verkehrt,
wenn es einen großen
Hersteller gibt,
der mit ordentlich Entwicklungspower
zumindest mal so
die Grundlagen hinstellt,
und
die Meute
vor vollendete Tatsachen stellt.
Ich glaube, dass es in manchen
Fällen, dass es einfach vorwärts
geht, gar nicht mal so verkehrt.
Wenn Microsoft heute,
ich werde mit euch,
ganz ehrlich, ich habe ernsthaft keinen Bock
auf einen Microsoft Desktop
unter Linux.
Vor allem nicht, wenn er so kacke ist
wie Windows.
Aber ohne Scheiß, wenn Microsoft
jetzt sagen würde,
wir setzen auf Linux,
wir bringen eine Oberfläche für Wayland
raus, da würde Microsoft
einfach ein Ja daran entwickeln,
auf alles
scheißen, was
die Wayland-Typen sagen, ob ihnen das
gefällt oder nicht, und am Ende
hätten wir eine Desktop-Oberfläche,
die wahrscheinlich ganz gut funktionieren würde,
abfuck zu benutzen wäre, weil die Microsoft-Leute
keine Ahnung haben, wie man eine gescheite Oberfläche
baut, aber die grundsätzlichen
Sachen so implementiert wären, dass sie
funktionieren. Und dann
würden sich wahrscheinlich alle an dem
Art und Weise orientieren,
wie das Microsoft gemacht hat,
und das hätte die ganze Sache
mit Sicherheit ein bisschen vorangebracht.
Auch wenn die Oberfläche wahrscheinlich für den Arsch wäre.
Aber da werden einfach ein paar
Sachen etabliert, und die Leute würden vor vollendete
Sachen stehen, so nach dem Motto, okay,
so benutzt man es halt nun mal, warum?
Ja, weil sich das Microsoft mal überlegt hat.
Ja, wie gesagt,
das ist ja auch der Grund, warum es VMware sich leisten
kann, und zu
sagen, uns interessiert
das schlicht und ergreifend nicht, ob unsere
GPU-Implementierung da
verkackt ist unter Linux.
Denen einfach egal. Oder für Wayland
verkackt ist, weil die Wayland-User
kannst du, VMware-Wayland-User, kannst du ja in
einer Hand abzählen, und
dann noch
die passende Desktop-Umgebung,
das kannst du knicken, ja.
Und manche kriegen es ja hin, ja. Ich bin mir ziemlich,
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass wenn ich ein aktuelles Gnome in der
VM starte, VMware, dass das Ganze funktionieren wird.
Auch mit X-Programm.
Wollen wir das mal machen? Machen wir jetzt.
Müssen wir nur eine Live-CD starten. Dauert zwei Minuten.
Wir starten jetzt mal ein aktuelles
Ubuntu, ich hab die VM schon gelöscht, ich kack nur.
Wir starten jetzt mal ein aktuelles Ubuntu.
Was ja unter, was ja, was ja mit Wayland
läuft. Ah, hier, zack.
Ja, fünf Kerne.
Acht Gigabyte.
Ah, kann ruhig mit Nutt laufen, ist
mir egal. Ja.
Printer weg.
Ah, Soundkarte, meinetwegen. Ah, zack.
Finish. So.
Das wird wahrscheinlich einfach laufen. Schauen
wir mal. Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ja, deswegen, ich kann,
ich verstehe das voll und ganz, dass die
Leute lieber macOS benutzen.
100 Pro?
Also, ich persönlich
bin auch kein großer Fan
der macOS GUI.
Aber du hast bei macOS wirklich
eine ganz gute Verbindung
aus, es ist
genug Linux drin,
bzw. BSD ist es ja eigentlich.
Es ist genug Unix unter der Haube
drin.
Ja, aktuell ist genau.
Und auch an
Linux Packages
gibt es genug, dass es dich nicht abfuckt.
...
prinzip jedes mac os exakt gleich aussieht das hat seine vor- und nachteile
ja gibt ja auch gibt ja nicht nur nachteile dadurch gibt ja auch vorteile
wenn du sagst okay das system ist überall einheitliche sieht wenigstens
überall nicht kacke aus mein mein fall ist es nicht ja und auch dass ich das
window management und herr merkel es ist alles super hakelig anfühlt aber kein
ding ist okay zumindest kannst du dich darauf verlassen dass es funktioniert
und nicht dass du ein programm startest und wenn es den google öffnen öffnen
willen kompletten desktop crasht also deswegen verstehe ich dass es viele
entwickler mögen weil du hast die kombination aus eigentlich so gut wie
alle entwickler tools command line tools ordentliches terminal hast mit item 2
beispielsweise auch du hast eine gute umgebung mit allen tools die du brauchst
ja docker und so ist halt vielleicht bissel eklig aber geht auch also das
meiste geht mittlerweile und du hast technisch alles da was du brauchst also
deswegen ich würde als entwickler auch mac os windows eindeutig
vorhaben
vorziehen linux nicht zumindest nicht in der art und weise wie ich es
eingerichtet habe aber wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste dazwischen kaputte
kaputtes wayland linux was sie richtig funktioniert windows oder mac os ich
würde auch mac os nehmen ja das stimmt schon natürlich apple hat
einen riesenvorteil dass sie den kram selbst baut wofür sie den kram
programmiert klar ist mir aber als user egal wenn du einfach was willst was
funktioniert ist das ist ja kein
richtiger pluspunkt so du kannst sagen ist halt so ich verstehe dass so ist
aber wie war das jetzt noch mal sich anzuzeigen lassen ob man unter wayland
läuft ich habe schon wieder vergessen habt habt install xs x11 app wayland
session oder irgendwie so ging das doch
ok
echo xtg irgendwas xtg session type
ach es ist x11 ok kann man nicht mittlerweile ist das nicht
standardmäßig wayland mittlerweile ubuntu hätte ich eigentlich gedacht aber
anscheinend nicht ok ja dann nicht aktuelles fedora nehmen hätte eigentlich gedacht
ja aber aktuelles fedora ist gut fedora ist so ein bisschen das vielleicht nicht beim live iso das stimmt schon
vielleicht nicht beim live iso das stimmt schon vielleicht nicht beim live iso das stimmt schon
Fedora ist ja so ein bisschen das Vorzeige Wayland Ding. Was ist denn das aktuelle? 40? Genau, jawoll.
Wieso sollte das Wayland sein? Weil ich dachte, dass es Default ist mittlerweile. Also Fedora
wahrscheinlich. Fedora die machen schon lange Werbung dafür, dass sie jetzt Default Wayland
haben. Schauen wir mal, wie es in der VM ist. Ja, so sehe ich das mit MacOS auch. Gibt es sogar Leute,
die verwenden Docker unter Windows, was halt richtig fake ist. Downloadet das jetzt irgendwas?
Ja, macht einfach gar nichts. Docker unter Windows ist halt richtig, richtig Fakeware.
Es ist ein Linux VM unter der Haube. Ja, muss ja. Docker unter jedem Betriebssystem außer Linux
muss fake... Wobei, der Fairness halber muss man das jetzt ja auch trennen zwischen Container Runs
Time und Docker. Docker ist ja letztendlich nur das, nehmen wir es mal, das UI dafür. Aber Linux
Container laufen halt nun mal nur unter Linux. Dementsprechend sind halt Linux Container unter
Mac und Windows Fake. Also irgendwelche VMs, wie es unter... Okay, Fedora boot nicht. Drauf
geschissen. Hat keinen Bock. Weg damit. M. Spend. Okay, Leute. Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen. Wenn
es euch gefallen hat, dann freue ich mich natürlich sehr, wenn ihr jetzt einmal Follow klickt.
Dann werde ich auch notifiziert beim nächsten Stream. Ich bin morgen früh wieder am Start,
so gegen neun, denke ich mal, so in dem Dreh. Also morgen hier, so irgendwann so irgendwie um neun Uhr
rum. Wer noch ein bisschen Geld an Bezos überweisen will und noch einen freien Prime Sub hat, freue ich
mich natürlich auch sehr drüber. Morgen neun Uhr bin ich wieder am Start. Gucken wir mal, was sich
die Woche so getan hat. Hab gesehen, es gibt ein neues. Ein neues Lohnsichters Video. Das guck ich
mal sonst gern. Mal schauen, was uns YouTube sonst noch so empfiehlt.
Was? Ein Tiefdrucker. Ein was? Äh, Kebab Chris und Don Sgitor. Subscription. Danke, Leute. Sehr,
sehr nice. Ich auch nicht. Ich geh jetzt auf. Wir hören uns morgen früh. Bis denn. See you.
Ciao.